[Musique]
Isabelle, bons bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Euh, j'ai 30 ans d'activisement en
écologie. Euh je suis ingénieur agronome
activiste, ça veut dire que j'ai jamais
milité dans une association ou un parti
politique. Donc j'ai toujours mis ce que
je faisais professionnellement au
service de mes convictions. Et ces 10
dernières années, je me suis consacrée
à la à savoir si on pouvait s'en sortir
par rapport au dérèglements climatiques
et à l'extinction de la biodiversité et
ça m'a amené à finalement
sortir une théorie économique, ce qui
est qui a été une découverte, c'était
pas voulu au départ qui s'appelle
l'économie symbiotique.
Vous avez participé à la réalisation
d'un documentaire, un film qui s'appelle
Hanis Bertrand. Oui.
Pourquoi avoir fait ça ? Ah
mais je en fait je travaillais avec
Yann. Je suis rentrée chez Yann en 2002.
J'avais adoré ces ces expos dans au sur
le jardin du Luxembourg et à ce
moment-là, je travailler pour les
syndicats des agriculteurs biologiques
et on avait c'était en 2000 à peu près
et alors que c'était quand même déjà
pionnier, on avait du mal à faire à
faire comprendre au consommateur
biologique que consommer biologique est
un acte politique en fait. Et quand je
suis arrivée dans ces photos,
j'ai été mais stupéfaite vraiment parce
que je me suis dit, il a compris, il a
compris comment passer un message, fle
en fait le cerveau et par la beauté de
ses images, la perte des échelles puis
on se dit qu'est-ce que c'est ? On lit
le texte, on s'aperçoit que c'est une
pollution, on s'aperçoit que c'est un
désastre sanitaire et tout à coup, on
relève la tête et on voit la photo
autrement. Et j'ai eu l'occasion, j'ai
su qui cherchait une rédactrice
scientifique en 2002. Et donc je suis
allée le je suis allée postuler puis
après moi je suis partie en fait il m'a
rappelé pour faire ces émissions de vue
du ciel et puis ensuite j'ai écrit home
h qui a été qui a été qui a été diffusé
dans 53 pays et on l'avait conçu
vraiment comme un film outil un film de
débat et c'est pour ça qu'il était
disponible gratuitement et il a été vu
par 800 millions de personnes
aujourd'hui.
Quel est votre constat euh
pour notre avenir proche et notre avenir
à moyen terme ?
Quelles sont les menaces que vous avez
identifié ?
Alors, on va partir du constat déjà, ben
ensuite, on partira on parlera des
menaces. Le constat, c'est que il y a
une dynamique aujourd'hui qui est
incroyable par rapport à moi il y a 30
ans quand j'ai commencé.
C'est euh
juste entre être l'agriculture
biologique et et Yan Artus Bertrand,
j'ai été prof en de SVT en science de la
vie et de la terre en lise. Et c'était
en 2000 et on
on
j'avais des premières S et je leur ai
parlé du changement climatique et du
protocole de Kyoto. Sur une classe de
30, il y avait trois personnes qui en
avaient entendu parler. D'accord ? 20
ans après, même 10 ans après, toute la
classe en aurait entendu parler. Et là
aujourd'hui, on a une dynamique qui
s'est propagée dans tous les milieux,
les milieux banquiers, les milieux euh
les milieux industriel, les milieux
populaires. déjà depuis 2002 2005 enfin
sur certains trucs non plutôt 2005007
on voit vraiment une tendance de fond
arrivé sur consommer local sur la prise
de conscience du changement climatique
et maintenant de l'extinction de la
biodiversité de la pollution qui
n'existait pas du tout mais pas du tout
ou peu en tout cas dans le dans
l'inconscient collectif dans les années
2000. Moi quand j'ai décidé de de faire
mes études en environnement agriculture
environnement j'avais fait c'était en 92
et je ne connaissais même pas Rio,
l'événement de Rio. C'està-dire que ça
diffusait pas ou peu et pourtant j'étais
concernée. Aujourd'hui, c'est plus du
tout le cas. Même dans les milieux très
très
euh partout en fait, c'est devenu un les
milieux les moins les moins politisés et
cetera. L'environnement est quelque
chose qui qui est une vraie conscience.
que les gens traient leurs déchets par
exemple alors que on sait que ça sert
enfin pour l'instant ça sert toujours
pas à grand-chose pas grand chose. Et
pourquoi c'est parce que les filières
les filières sont très très mal les
filières sont très très mal
arrive très peu à recycler en réalité 7
% seulement du plastique est recyclé et
et les gens pourtant ont bien leurs deux
trois poubelles et ils se prennent la
tête pour trier et et c'est profondément
créé en fait. Donc je trouve que ça ça
cette dynamique là, elle est assez
incroyable. Maintenant dans la dynamique
des changement des des de l'état
équilibre écologique global de la Terre,
on nen sait rien. On sait que on a
peut-être dépassé les seuils qui nous
emmènent vraiment dans un autre état
équilibre d'équilibre global de la
Terre. Donc ça veut dire qu'on ne peut
pas savoir vers quelle terre on va hein.
Ça veut dire que elle va se comporter
différemment. C'est plus le même état
d'équilibre écologique global. Donc soit
on a dépassé ses seuils et on y est et
on ne le on ne pourra plus l'éviter,
soit on y est pas encore mais on sait
que c'est proche.
Quelles sont les menaces que vous avez
identifié pour vous la la principale
menace ? La principale menace euh c'est
de perdre les services rendus par les
écosystèmes vivants. Donc on voit déjà
que la production d'oxygène diminue. Euh
c'est ressources
euh c'est une étude de nature, je crois.
Faut aller regarder. C'est récent. Euh
on voit que l'Antarctique se se commence
à se à se à se fondre à se fendre en
fait. Donc la calotte glacière commence
à être fragilisée. Ce qui est ça c'est
très important parce que c'est pas
seulement la montée du niveau de la mer
mais ça veut dire que ça réveille les
failles tectoniques.
On on sait donc le la fréquence des
inondations des ouragans, des
sécheresses qui va augmenter. Et donc
tel qu'on est parti là, on peut avoir
une on peut avoir en fait une les
surfaces inhabitables de la terre, ne
serait-ce que pour des conditions de
chaleur et d'humidité qui vont concerner
2 à 5 milliards de personnes.
Donc
plus de 300 jours par an. Donc autant
dire que les gens ne vont pas rester là.
Donc voilà. Et euh et c'est très
important ça parce que si en fait les
services rendus par les écosystèmes
vivants tombent, vous n'êtes plus
protégé du vent. En fait, on se rend pas
compte mais les
qu'est-ce qui fait des brises sur terre
?
Ben, c'est le fait qu'il y ait des
arbres, c'est le fait qu'il y ait du
vivant. Au début de la Terre, il n'y
avait que des tempêtes, il y avait que
les les les cycles atmosphériques qu'on
a sur n'importe quelle planète qui a une
Oui, parce que aussi il y a des écarts
de température parce qu'il y a jour nuit
parce que ça
Oui,
parce que sur sur Jupiter sur Jupiter,
il y a des brises à 1500 kmh. Et c'est
ça. Donc c'est des tempêtes et des
ouragans.
Vous voyez ? et la rosée, la brume et
cetera, c'est lié aux écosystèmes
vivants. La régulation de la
température, la régulation du chaud, du
froid et cetera, c'est lié aux
écosystèmes vivants. Et on le voit déjà
en fait l'été quand on a des canicules,
en fait, on se réfugie dans des bureaux
climatisés, accentu encore le problème
du coup. Donc en fait la vie ne devient
plus possible que dans des conditions
artificialisées.
Conditions artificialisées, ça veut dire
beaucoup beaucoup de technologies
pour survivre et donc ça veut dire les
entreprises les plus capitalistiques et
ça veut dire aussi des atmosphères de
plus en plus contrôlées. Et donc on
ouvre la voie à une perte de liberté
totale et qui parce que ces écosystèmes
artificialisés
seront accessibl bien plus facilement
aux plus riches et au moins libre.
Donc la perte des services rendus par
les écosystèmes vivants qui sont en
train de s'effondrer.
Si on arrive à ce stade-là, on aura
énormément de mal à retrouver une
société libre, démocratique et cetera.
On aura pas le temps de faire les
combats sociaux. L'autre urgence, c'est
celle-là, c'est d'avoir de de se
continuer à se battre sur la liberté,
sur la non surveillance, notamment sur
internet, notamment sur le le fait de
pouvoir euh de de pouvoir s'exprimer
librement et cetera, des manifestations
et cetera. euh absolument euh euh se
battre sur ça, se battre sur la liberté
d'internet parce que pour moi c'est en
tout cas le l'enjeu l'enjeu démocratique
le plus grave aujourd'hui. Voilà, on a
besoin des deux mais vous voyez les deux
sont liés. on n'aura pas une sauvegarde
et une une
un réveil de la planète et des des
actions et cetera euh de de de la
l'ensemble de la population qui veut y
passer pour pouvoir faire un miroir
social, pour pouvoir faire un mouvement
de masse si on n' pas cette liberté
d'expression et de débat parce qu'elle
vient de la base le débat et on ne
pourra plus le faire si ces écosystèmes
vivants seront perdus. Est-ce que vous
connaissez la fonction exponentielle ?
Oui.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me parler de la
fonction exponentielle ?
Ben, vous voulez dire une la courbe, ce
qu'on appelle la courbe en cross de OK,
par exemple. La fonction exponentielle,
c'est simple, c'est quand je vais vous
on va prendre sur l'exemple des réseaux
par exemple,
on peut le prendre sur la démographie.
On peut le prendre sur Oui, mais en fait
Ah oui, alors je vois où vous voulez en
venir. En ce moment, on est à toutes les
exponentiels. La démographie est
exponentielle, le l'augmentation des
températures est exponentielle. La
concentration de la richesse est
exponentielle, la la
à peu près tout est exponentiel. Les
près tout
la connerie.
Non, je crois pas.
La connerie n'est pas exponentielle.
Ça dépend où, chez les dirigeants ou en
bas.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la
démographie est un problème dans ce
monde d'après ?
Alors, si on prend la question de la
démographie,
si on regarde les populations qui font
le moins d'enfants,
lesquelles consomment le plus de
ressources entre celles qui font le
moins d'enfants et le plus d'enfants sur
dans le monde ? Je pose la question.
J'ai la réponse. La réponse c'est les
pays occidentaux, les enfut de pays
occidentaux consomment 10 ou 100 fois
plus
80 un peu plus 80% des ressources des
ressources consommées sont par les pays
riches qui font le moins d'enfants.
Entre les jeunes et les vieux qui
consomme le plus qui a la plus grande
empreinte
entre plus de 60 ans à peu près et avant
60 ans
oui les plus âgés. Ensuite, je vais vous
poser euh la Est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on peut nourrir tout le monde ? Quel
est le problème de la démographie ?
Problème de la démographie, il est
surtout dans par exemple des villes
comme la GS qui donc au Nigéria qui vont
augmenter brutalement de population et
vont avoir aucun urbanisme. Violence
augmentée, plus de pas de accès à l'eau
difficile, pas de conditions sanitaires,
prostitution, violence, marché noir et
cetera.
Pourquoi la population vient se
concentrer à la gousse ? Parce que les
terres agricoles sont prises, sont
accaparé par des grands fonds
d'investissement, par d'autres pays et
cetera et ça produit une migration
rurale et après on va vous dire qu'on
peut pas nourrir toute la planète.
Vous voyez, c'est autre chose. Ensuite,
ensuite, moi franchement l'espoir que
j'ai le plus là, c'est la jeune
génération qui me la donne. Parce que
là, la un pays jeune, il sait s'adapter.
Un pays vieux ne sait pas s'adapter. Et
je suis vraiment très contente que les
gens aient fait des enfants il y a 15 à
20 ans alors qu'on parlait déjà de pour
l'écologie de diminuer la population. Le
problème de parler de la démographie,
c'est que on a encore une vision
quantitative
alors que donc c'est toujours plus ou
moins de la même chose alors qu'on voit
bien que en fait la réponse à nos
problèmes c'est plus d'autres choses.
Et donc c'est pas une vision
quantitative.
La jeunesse là, elle va nous permettre
d' nous adapter. Elle va peut-être nous
permettre de passer le cap parce qu'elle
pense autrement.
parce qu'elle pense autrement et
heureusement qu'on les a fait ces
enfants là. Donc voilà, c'est c'est
toujours cette façon de penser la
quantité déjà quand on parle de la
démographie au lieu de de penser comment
on fait autrement.
J'ai écouté avant que vous arriviez une
de vos interviews, vous parliez de la
la pollution de l'eau et comment traiter
la pollution de l'eau avec la terre,
avec les jardins. Est-ce que vous pouvez
en parler un petit peu ? Alors, en fait
la aujourd'hui, on traite les eaux usées
euh par des grosses centrales
d'épuration donc qui sont du béton avec
des des des bassins de décantation qui
euh vous voyez enfin tout le monde
connaît les centrales d'épuration qu'on
doit contourner et cetera. Elles sont
intraversables et en plus elle donc du
béton, des armures métalliques, de
l'énergie et cetera et elle dépolue à
peu près 50 % he de la pollution.
Ensuite, on on met dans le milieu
naturel pour pour terminer la
dépollution. Et en fait, il se trouve
que l'eau
l'eau existe dans la même quantité
depuis toujours sur la terre. Elle est
constamment réutilisée et recyclée et
réépurée pour avoir une eau propre et
potable pour tous les êtres vivants. Les
êtres vivants savent très bien dépolluer
l'eau. Et ça c'est le lagunage aussi
classique qu'on connaissait au 19e début
du 20e siècle et qui demandait 12 m² par
équivalent un bit. Aujourd'hui, en fait,
en architecturant ses jardins sans du
tout modifier les plantes, en mettant
des jeuns,
des bambous, des roseaux, puis des iris,
des mantes aquatiques, des Sagittaires,
puis la dernière étape des nénupares qui
en fait ont besoin d'une qualité d'eau
assez pure pour pouvoir se développer,
une qualité proche de l'eau de baignade
et c'est pas encore l'eau potable, c'est
de l'eau de baignade. Et bien vous allez
avoir sur l'équivalent d' 1,5 de 0,5 à 3
m²
pour les eau usé d'un équivalent
habitant la possibilité au lieu de 12
avant
la possibilité d'épurer toutes les eaux
usées y compris les eaux noires. Et ça
c'est énorme parce que les noir c'est
les eaux des toilettes pardon.
Et ça c'est énorme parce que ça veut
dire que un immeuble de 30 habitants ou
de 100 habitants, vous avez besoin de 50
à 300 m² de jardin.
Et vous pouvez aller jusqu'à la la l'eau
potable par d'autres filtres avec des
verrs de terre, des lombré compostes et
enfin des lombré des lombr files.
Tu peux me faire l'avocat du diable ?
Ouais. Non
mais attendez attendez moi mais juste
pour dire aussi en fait la dernière
étape c'est l'oxygénation de l'eau et ça
demande des cascad fontaines c'està-dire
que c'est extrêmement beau et les gens
en fait s'y retrouvent pour pouvoir se
retrouver socialement piquenniquer et
cetera.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Oui ça y est.
Bon il y a combien de il y a combien
d'habitants à Paris ? 21000 habitants
parm kè carr c'est c'est la une 7è ville
la plus dense au monde mais je sais plus
combien
c'est 21700 de têtes au kilomètre
carrou
il faut combien de superficie de jardin
mais en fait j'avais fait les calculs
justement pour une ville de 15000
habitants par kilomè carr et c'est
énorme he 15000 parce que si vous prenez
entre Marseille, Amsterdam, Strasbourg,
Lille, on est entre 3500 et 6500
habitants par kilomètre. carré. Donc et
même une ville de 15000 et bien vous
pouvez la rendre euh avec des rendements
de permaculture, pas des afficionnés
d'ose de la permaculture moyen du
filtrage d'eau là.
Ah ben le filtrage ça prend ça prend
quelques places en fait. Ça prend
quelques places, quelques rues, quelques
squar. Non, c'est pas énorme. Non. Par
contre à Paris, ce qui est plus
difficile c'est que le sous-sol est un
gruère et des carrières.
Voilà. et la carrière et métro ég euh ça
fait beaucoup de superficie. Euh on va
on va revenir sur ce sur ce côté. Non,
ça fait très peu de superficie, je vous
dis. Euh
s'il faut 3 m² par habitant.
Non non, ben c'est un immeuble un
immeuble de 100 d'habitants
c'est moins que la quantité d'espace
vert requise pour les nouvell les
nouvelles habitations.
D'accord.
Voilà.
Euh on va reparler économie. On va
reparler économie. Euh
euh votre théorie économique, elle a été
perçue et reçue comment par les
afficionados des salons feutrés des
économistes ? Alors très différemment
euh certains économistes ont dit c'est
une rupture, ça pas été publié savoir
quand c'est des échos que j'ai
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse des articles
dessus d'ailleurs. Euh donc qui disent
c'est une vraie rupture et d'ailleurs là
en ce moment je suis en train de de
monter une chair avec avec une grande
université française avec le Knam et par
un qui sera dirigé par un économiste euh
et
économiste de quelle école ? Euh, il
s'appelle Philippe Durance et il est
spécialiste de l'innovation sociale.
Mais moi, je suis pas économiste en fait
donc je peux pas vous donner les
Les plus belles découvertes sont souvent
faites par les néophites.
Et euh et donc euh donc voilà. Non, en
fait non, j'ai plutôt eu des bons
retours en fait, même des économistes.
Gael Gérô a fait un bon très bon retour
de de l'économie symbique par exemple.
Et et Goldman Sax vous a contacté ?
Non. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez ?
Des banques ? Oui, on contact mon
contact.
Quelle banque ?
Je peux pas vous le dire parce que quand
on on pourra faire des choses ensemble,
je pourrais le dire mais pas pour
l'instant. Euh mais des individus dans
des banques. Oui.
Et pour monter des indicateurs vraiment
sur la régénération écologique,
économique et sociale. Parce que
aujourd'hui les banques, elles sont
confrontées à quoi ? Elles peuvent plus
sécuriser leurs actifs. Qui peut
sécuriser ces actifs aujourd'hui à 2 3
ans et même ben on le voit à 3 mois avec
le Covid là ? que ce soit de
l'immobilier, de ça peut être emporté
par une tempête, une inondation, crise
sociale, crise économique. En fait, les
actifs ne sont presque plus enfin voilà,
on peut plus beaucoup sécuriser les
actifs. Et donc, on a besoin de de
certaines banques sont mais le milieu de
la finance commence à être intéressé par
les indicateurs de résilience, donc de
régénération écologique, économique et
sociale.
On va se
se poser plus de questions concernant la
psychologie qu'il faut à une société
pour s'adapter à une société en
changement. Est-ce que vous pensez que
la psychologie de la population
va pouvoir s'adapter sans heure, sans
éléments exotiques fédérateurs, sans
Est-ce que vous pensez que la
philosophie, la psychologie de la
population face à ce problème de
changement ne va pas créer des comment
on appelle ça ? une une tétanie de de la
population face au changement. Là, on
voit avec le déconfinement, il y a eu
des grandes que chez McDonald,
il y a eu des grandes que chez chez
beaucoup de choses.
On a vu quelques gens se réapproprier
dans Paris, les espaces verts, mais ça
reste complètement minoritaire. Est-ce
que vous pensez pas que la l'inertie de
la société,
la le côté vieillissant de la société
en fait nous emmène à pas du tout
d'action ?
En fait, je pense que le
comme je vous disais, il y a un vrai
changement dans la population de fond et
que ce soit les les études d'opinion,
les études sociologiques, même les
études mythologiques, hein, la
mythologie dominante d'une population
montre que non, la conscience écologique
et le sentiment d'appartenance à la
terre est grandissant.
Euh ce qui ne fait pas ce qui est fou,
c'est que on ne on ne le reconnaît pas,
on le voit pas, on se sent isolé parce
qu'il y a un miroir social qui est
extrêmement important, c'est les médias
dominants, donc les médias les médias
notamment de la télévision ou des grands
journaux et le politique national, le
politique le politique en général mais
surtout le politique national. Et tant
que lui ne n'envoie pas ses signaux de
on a changé, la société ne se reconnaît
pas. Mais on est tous hein victime de
ça. Euh vous allez croire au fond ce qui
est dit par la télé globalement hein. Je
parle pas forcément on est de plus en
plus sceptique par rapport à ce qui est
dit sur la télé he ça c'est c'est des
études le montent très bien mais
globalement si vous n'êtes pas
spécialiste d'un sujet ou si vous ne
creusez pas les études vous allez vous
tromper en fait et vous sur le vous
allez voir votre société comme vous les
renvoie ses miroirs sociaux.
Et en ça, on est tous concernés. Moi, je
le sais par sur les études et ce qu' les
sujets qui m'intéressent que je creuse,
je suis sûre que je suis complètement
dupe sur d'autres domaines.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous définir ce
qu'est le concept d'économie
symbiotique, d'économie circulaire ?
Alors, l'économie symbiotique, c'est euh
ce que j'ai sorti il y a en livre il y a
2 ans 2 ans et demi à peu près, en 2017,
fin 2017, qui est euh la l'observation
de de qui qui est issue du de
l'observation de euh des
logiques économiques et productives qui
devaient répondre à deux choses au
départ. un diminuer structurellement les
impacts écologiques sur les écosystèmes
planétaires et de les restaurer et en
produisant et en trouvant leur marché.
Voilà. et euh et ça m'a amené à à en
découvrir plein dans absolument tous les
pays, dans les milieux pauvres comme
riches, euh chaud comme froid, euh
urbain comme rurau et puis à se rendre
me rendre compte qu'en fait non
seulement ils étaient en fait ils
étaient quand ils avaient ces effetsl,
on pouvait les décrire par les mêmes
principes de fonctionnement. On voyait
vraiment une architecture se dégager de
de ces principes. Il fonctionn en
écosystème en fait. Et j'ai dégagé six
principes qui me permettaient de
discriminer ce qui était les fausses
bonnes solutions, des vraies bonnes
solutions. Ces principes, ils sont très
simples, on les connaît tous en fait,
notamment dans le milieu de la
transition, mais ils sont vraiment
discriminants. Un, il repose sur la
diversité.
Il faut une diversité comme dans un
écosystème vivant qui va permettre en
fait une résilience, une autonomie et
cetera. Et il faut que cette diversité
des éléments des acteurs, elle puissent
euh euh partager en fait ses ressources
sur un flux commun et sans
centralisation, une territorialisation
des flux, mais qui repose aussi parce
queon est quand même des êtres humains
sur des valeurs communes, un territoire
de valeur commun et aussi un territoire
d'intérêt et de besoins commun ou
convergant. Et euh ça c'est le deuxième.
Donc ça là vous allez avoir ben par
exemple les toute la les et pardon
toutes toutes les les économies en
réseau. Les économies en réseau, le le
même une plateforme de réseau social en
fait chacun contribue mais ses
ressources informationnelles, ce que
vous voulez
c'est ses bons conseils, c'est chacun
contribue directement. Ça c'est le trè
principe. La coopération est directe. Et
ça en fait c'est les bases d'un
écosystème. C'est les bases d'un
écosystème vivant. C'est les bases aussi
d'un écosystème social et aussi d'un
écosystème industriel économique euh
technique comme on peut le voir dans
l'économie circulaire.
Donc ça c'est le 4e principe. Ça va
produire des écosystèmes dont on va
utiliser les services. Mais pour que ça
se maintienne, il faut justement
utiliser les services de cet écosystème.
Donc ça peut être le big data par
exemple l'écosystème de données. On va
favoriser
les les données, la production de
données, donc la l'activité de cet
écosystème social pour en retirer les
données. de service rendu par cet
écosystème et on va chercher
l'efficience parce que s'il y a trop de
désordre dans la diversité, ça va
exploser. Donc il y a un équilibre comme
ça. Et le 6e principe c'est vraiment ça
ça permet de de réguler la diversité des
matériaux notamment, c'est le respect de
de s'inclure dans les équilibres
écologiques et physiologiques de la
planète Terre. vous avez beau recycler
du bisphénol A, il sera toujours aussi
toxique et même pire continuera encore
plus à se diffuser. Donc donc voilà, ça
c'est les six principes.
Tous ces écosystèmes fonctionnent comme
ça. Maintenant, ils peuvent être très
prédateurs de leur contributeur
notamment s'ils ont pas leur
gouvernance. Donc en fait, il faut que
ces principes pour être productifs
s'appliquent à la production. Et là,
vous avez des écosystèmes hyper
productifs, mais hyper productifs comme
la permaculture par exemple dans le
vivant, comme Google, comme Facebook et
cetera dans les datas. Euh, il faut
qu'il s'applique euh aux usagers et euh
et notamment par exemple quand il
s'applique production usager, vous
fermez le cercle entre les producteurs
et les usagers. C'est là que vous
arrivez à euh à par exemple un
écosystème de voiture.
Lorsque vous le fabricant reste
possesseur de la voiture et bien
lorsqu'elle est usagée, elle revient au
fabricant. C'est-à-dire que les
utilisateurs vont pouvoir ne vont pas la
posséder mais vont pouvoir l'utiliser.
Elle va revenir au fabricant. Et là, on
a des facteurs 16 de diminution de
matière. 10, 15, 16 par exemple.
simplement parce qu'elle revient en
fabricant qui va réutiliser les
composants. On a la même chose pour des
bouteilles de bière au Québec
qui sont réutiliser recyclé alors que
c'est du verre et mais on a à peu près
ce facteur 15 aussi constamment. Donc ça
c'est important et surtout surtout la
gouvernance.
La gouvernance parce que si on n pas ces
six principes sur la gouvernance
et bien c'est-à-dire que là on a on
aboutit à des coopératives ou à ce qu'on
appelle la gouvernance et bien commun.
et bien le partage de la valeur n'est
pas redistribué.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on voit bah vous par
exemple, vous vivez de vos
contributeurs,
vous vivez de ceux qui consomment votre
émission, consomme les services que vous
produisez. C'est pour ça que vous
permettez vous vous subsistez en fait.
Et et bien on a bien cette diversité en
fait des acteurs qui viennent vous
financer et qui vont permettre votre
liberté.
et en même temps de vous pouvoir vous
régénérer économiquement et cetera et
cetera. Voilà, donc il y a ça, c'est six
principes. Il faut absolument qu'il soit
s'il y a pas la gouvernance et la
redistribution de la valeur et bien on a
pas de régénération sociale
tout simplement.
Une question de GG. Alors, la symbiose
dont le vivant, c'est le monde des
bisouours point d'interrogation. Les
fourmis, elles vivent en symbiose avec
les pucer ou sont-elles des exploiteuses
? point d'intervention
elles ne vivent alors je suis pas une
spécialiste assez je sais ce que
j'aimerais si je vois à peu près mais en
fait c'est fabuleux les fourmis en effet
elles élèvent plein de trucs elles
cultivent et tout et mais je ne sais pas
quel est le la rétribution qu'on les
puceron dans le dans les fourmis en fait
non hein la symbiose c'est pas d'abord
on est c'est line Margulis qui a montré
ça dans les années 70 c'est que nous
sommes tous symbiotes du notre d'un are
être vivant. En fait, la symbiose est un
mécanisme général du vivant. Mais
lorsque la symbiose se passe mal, non,
ça par exemple, il y a les les
légumineuses, c'est c'est des plantes
qui où vous avez qui sont adaptées à une
bactérie qui s'appelle un nitrobactère
et qui va permettre de synthétiser à
partir de l'azote de l'ure de l'azote
qui va les nourrir elle en fait de du
nitrate des nitrates, des nitrites comme
les engrais, vous voyez. C'est pour ça
qu'on a pas besoin d'engrais pour les
légumineuses. Et et bien si la bactérie
est mauvaise ouvrière, pouf, la
légumineuse, elle cesse son apport
d'oxygène à la bactérie. La bactérieur
pour que une autre vienne la remplacer.
Non, il faut une il faut une
réciprocité. La symbiose ne marche pas
sans réciprocité.
Question d'internet. Cette fameuse
économie symbiotique virgule, c'est
l'économie de la commune au Moyen-Âge.
Pointinterrogation.
C'est proche mais avec les technologies
d'aujourd'hui. Ouais. Alors, c'est quoi
l'économie une reconnexion vivant ?
C'est quoi l'économie de la commune au
Moyen-Âge ? C'est-à-dire que
je suis pas non plus une historienne
spécialiste des communes, mais
en fait on observe au Moyen-Âge central,
je crois et en fait et et au moment de
toutes les mouvements des communes des
villes franches, euh un vrai en fait une
réappropriation d'abord des moyens
énergétiques par la population, les
moulins euh les moulins qui sont c'est
fou hein, les moulins, on avait un
nombre de jusquici encore jusqu'à il y a
peu de moulins en Europe, c'était
incroyable. ça approvisionnait
ça alimentait les forges, ça alimentait
les meneries, ça alimentait en énergie
tout un tas de services et qui était en
fait en effet
euh euh
produit en commun, euh géré en commun et
on avait un un tas de un tas de les
pâturages en commun, les certains champs
en commun, certains voilà et ça ça a
donné en fait ces moyens énergétiques
notamment et certains Certains aussi
moyens mécaniques ont permis en fait de
de d'accroître la richesse et la
productivité
des bourgeois, des habitants des bourgs
et de au fur et à mesure pouvoir
euh se se révolter contre l'impôt des
seigneurs et de permettre de dicter
leurs conditions. Donc les villes
franches, si je me souviens bien, les
villes franches, c'est c'est un ça s'est
fait notamment sur le par rapport au
pouvoir féodal et les communes, ça s'est
fait plus dans le sud de la France par
rapport au pouvoir religieux qui faisait
la même chose he qui prélevait l'impro.
Autre questionnet, elle a donné une
conférence au salon vivre autrement avec
Thierry Kazanova. Était-elle au courant
du programme avant d'y aller ?
Je m'en souviens pas. Non, j'ai refusé.
Je sais que j'ai pas pu aller à une
conférence vivre autrement. il y a 2
ans, je crois non, il y a 1 an et demi,
j'avais été bloquée, j'étais malade. Et
euh et sinon, j'en ai faite une mais il
y a très très longtemps avant la sortie
de mon livre, il y a au moins 5 6 ans.
Alors, je connais je connais pas Thierry
Casanova mais il y a beaucoup de
questions concernant ce monsieur-là. Que
pense-t-elle de Thierry Casanova et de
ses conseils dangereux, le crudorisme et
cetera et cetera et son mouvement
régénération.
Ah oui. Alors c'est ça le problème avec
le mot régénération, c'est que vous avez
aussi même des labos de de régénératif
très proche du transhumanisme.
Non, je le connais pas en fait. Monsieur
Casanova. Casanova, c'est ça.
Elle le connaît pas. Alors, quelle
différence entre son économie
symbiotique et l'économie bleue de
Gunter Pauli ? Alors, c'est convergant,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a plein aujourd'hui
de concepts qui convergent et l'économie
bleue, bah si je me souviens bien, il y
a 12 ou 18 principes ou 16 et en fait on
peut expliquer les les mais je pas
obtenu par la même méthode les les les
10 principes par les six principes de le
système logique de l'économie
symbiotique. En fait, ce qui amène le
symbiotique, c'est c'est des conditions
nécessaires et suffisantes. C'est une
démonstration apparemment du premier
ensemble. pourrait y en avoir d'autres
hein de conditions nécessaires et
suffisantes. Et ça ça vous permet en
fait de faire des équations des
équations pour
pouvoir parce que vous n'avez pas de
doublon en fait entre une entre une
variable qui va dire ça une variable. Il
faut absolument qu'elle soit
indépendante et
enfin qu'elle disent pas deux fois la
même chose si vous les additionnez ou
les multipliez. Et en effet le système
logique symbiotique amène ça en fait. Il
amène un ensemble de principes et de
lois qui donne un ensemble de conditions
nécessaires et suffisantes. Et ces
variables sont pas toutes quantitative,
ça peut être des variables de valeur.
C'est-à-dire oui, non, comme un
algorithme. C'est-à-dire que si les
acteurs ne partagent pas les mêmes
valeurs, et ça c'est pas quantitatif
mais c'est une variable, et bien il y a
très peu de chance que le système qu'ils
vont mettre en place perdure.
C'est vraiment une économie qui repose
sur les valeurs.
Vous vous dans dans certaines de vos
interviews, vous faites référence aux
cultures tribales au
au culture tribal au aux populations
dans dans la jungle en Amazonnie et
ainsi de suite. Euh qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire chez eux ? Et
je vais venir à ma deuxième question qui
est là pour faire un peu l'avocaté du
diable.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de de ces
cultures qui par exemple quand un vieux
arrive plus à marcher en forêt, bah il
le laisse avec 3 jours de de nourriture
et puis elle vient que pour r
poussé jusque jusque là ? Est-ce que
quel est votre idéal de société ?
Comment si si demain je vous donne une
baguette magique,
je vous Ouais,
je vous mets je vous mets plein pouvoir,
vous décrétez quoi ? Une théocratie, une
dictature, une démocratie ? Vous
décrétez quoi ? Une société basée sur
les fondements purs de d'une vraie d'un
vrai anarchisme dans le le mot le mot
euh euh
pas une anomie, un anarchisme. C'est ça
que vous dites.
Si
pas l'anomie, l'anarchisme tout à fait.
On se on se C'est quoi vous vous faites
quoi et vous agissez comment ?
Alors, on va peut-être répondre sur les
tribus indigen d'abord.
Alors, pourquoi ? Parce que quand
j'entends t tous ces nouveaux courants,
ça ressemble un peu à de la
gourouisation. Ça ressemble un peu à bou
bou bou bou bou bou les petits bisoun
noours. On va faire des petits
nénuphares. Moi, je vais je me pose je
me fais la voc diable en tant qu' je
suis un grand industriel et je vous
entends. D'accord. Ce système peut
soutenir combien de personnes ? Il peut
donner à manger à combien de personnes ?
Est-ce qu'il est résilient ? ce qui
Mais là ça fait beaucoup de questions à
la fois parce que vous abordez vraiment
beaucoup de choses différentes.
Je j'ess je vais essayer de partir déjà
du point commun. Je pense que le point
commun c'est quand vous parlez bisous
nours, on est fait petites fleurs,
petits oiseaux, des ninfardes pour pour
épurer l'eau. C'est c'est euh c'est la
la
séparation avec le vivant.
On est une société qui c'est une
civilisation qui s'est profondément
séparé du vivant et ça c'est vous savez
vous connaissez le le l'écrit le plus
ancien qu'on est retrouvé dans nos
civilisations.
Alors c'est un écrit vous parlez sur
papier sur pierre ou sur bois ?
L'écrit le récit en tout cas c'est
l'épopée de Guilgamèche à peu près
l'épopée de Guilgamèche à peu près 3000
ans avant Jésus-Christ. C'est ce fameux
prince qui a été qui a été cherché un
dieu.
C'est ça. C'était le roi de le roi d'our
et qui euh qui c'est
iranien, c'est ça ? Euh non, enfin c'est
c'est le c'est Sumer, c'est c'est Iran,
Irak, c'est les maris Mésopotam, enfin
les anciens marésopotamiens
euh c'est euh et c'est toute la
civilisation de Sumer. Donc on est
vraiment héritié en fait les vrais on
est vraiment héritier de la civilisation
de Sumer. Et l'objet de sa quête c'est
de tuer Umbaba, l'esprit de la forêt. Le
premier récit qu'on retrouve de notre
civilisation, c'est celui-là. Et on y
est toujours en fait, on y est toujours.
Est encore dans une fable.
On est Non, on est toujours dans cette
séparation du vivant. Il faut tuer
l'esprit de la forêt. On a peur du
vivant. Regardez que le coronavirus
comment il est traité en faitin. On on
nous parle de la vie en fait hein, des
réflexes des gestes de vie et et en fait
on a on on propose et surtout en France
des gestes barrières
des la distanciation sociale
et des des mesures très dévitalisantes.
on peut plus aller honorer nos morts
pendant le confinement, ce qui est ce
qui donne des traumatismes
psychologiques terribles. Donc il y a il
y a un on a du mal avec la vie et ça ça
nous vient même de Pythagore. Pythagore.
En fait, c'est ça qui est fabuleux,
c'est que il c'est pour ça qu'il tient
les mathématiques d'ailleurs comme les
comme la l'esprit par excellence en
fait, comme la la science enfin comme la
discipline par excellence parce que les
mathématiques sont pas une science hein,
c'est un c'est un construction logique.
Et bien parce que le le parce que on va
dans plus la vie organique est mauvaise.
Rent l'explique très bien dans la
condition humaine au tout début. Elle
explique combien en fait pour les Grecs
la vie bonne est une vie non organique
qui est très coupée de l'organique. On a
un vrai problème avec le vivant. Et
alors moi ce qui me fascine aussi depuis
quelques temps, c'est un jour quelqu'un
me dit en fait l'éthique du moine soldat
et quelle est en fait la la qui est très
valorisé l'éthique du moind soldat et
notamment dans notre milieu, le
sacrifice et cetera. Or quel est le
point commun entre le moine et le soldat
? C'est le sacrifice de la vie. Et vous
regardez toutes nos grandes religions
qui ont fondé en fait notre nos sociétés
occidentales.
Pourquoi Abraham devient le père des
croyants ? Je vous parle pas des textes
précis, je vous parle dans l'image dans
notre imaginaire. Ce qui a fait notre
collectif, c'est en acceptant de
sacrifier son fils que finalement il ne
sacrifie pas. Jésus, le Christ pareil,
il a donné sa vie pour nous et c'est
pour ça qu'il nous c'est pour ça qu'on a
la preuve de son amour. Vous vous rendez
compte si je devais sacrifier ma vie
pour prouver à mes enfants que je les
aime,
on a une conception en fait de de la de
de de la vie et et une idée du une
glorification du sacrifice de la vie qui
est terrible dans notre société et qui
nous fonde en fait. Ça fait 30 ans que
je suis là-dedans. Ça fait euh j'essaie
de trouver le J'aimerais en faire mon
prochain livre d'ailleurs, mais le
problème c'est là, c'est que j'ai pas le
temps d'écrire. Mais plus on tire la
ficelle, plus on voit que vraiment ce
qui un des un des des points, il y en a
pas qu'un jamais, mais un des points
fondamentaux de ce qui nous arrive, une
crise écologique incroyable, c'est qu'on
s'est complètement trompé là-dessus. On
sacrifie la vie, c'est glorifiant chez
nous. de sacrifier la vie. Donc
forcément, comment voulez-vous qu'on
n'arrive pas là ? Voilà ça, je pense ça
aujourd'hui et pour les tribus
indigènes, en fait, j'ai eu l'occasion
de rencontrer des tribus indigènes des
chefs et des chamans.
Euh alors en Europe où il y avait un
rassemblement de de chefs et chaman de
des cinq continents.
C'était dans le 16e ?
Non, c'était en Suisse mais oui, c'était
pas je suis jamais allée là-bas moi mais
et donc avec beaucoup de discussions,
beaucoup de débats et cetera sur
finalement ce queon peut s'amener chacun
pour sortir de la crise, rencontrer des
activistes européens en fait.
Déjà pris de la yawaska ?
Non, jamais.
Vous savez ce que c'est ?
Oui. Oui. Ben en fait les achatinka qui
que sont qui faisaient d'ailleurs partie
de ce rassemblement sont un peuple
gardien de la yawaska.
Mais non, enfin oui, je sais ce que
c'est mais j'en ai jamais pris non moi.
Et euh et si vous voulez ces dialogues
leur
leur conception du monde, leur vision du
monde, c'est très intéressant. C'est des
homo sapiens comme nous.
C'est-à-dire que ils se posent des
questions, ils ont une façon de faire
une science, ils ont envie de de de ils
sont enfin je veux dire c'est c'est des
homospiens. Si vous si on était né
là-bas, on aurait cette culture là. Et
ces visions du monde, on a vraiment
besoin de les connecter aujourd'hui et
de dialoguer pour pouvoir savoir ce que
c'est qu'un homosafience.
on a et et et challenger la vision
occidentale de ce que nous sommes parce
que franchement aujourd'hui on n pas
compris. Il me semble qu'on a des
preuves claires
de notre place dans le monde. On n pas
compris. On a une vision fausse de ce
qu'est la la
vision de l'homo sapiens dans le monde
quoi. Et sa place. C'est quoi la vraie
vision pour vous ?
Je n'en sais rien.
C'est à nous de la construire mais on
doit s'interroger.
Alors comment on pouvait dire que on
s'est trompé ? Bah,
on a commencé par euh dire les menaces
qui pesaient sur l'humanité avec 300
jours létaux par an avant la fin du
siècle qui vont concerner 2 à 5
milliards de personnes.
L'Antarctique qui se qui est en train de
péter comme bulle de champagne, je cite
dans un le scientifique qui l'a qui l'a
qui l'a qui l'a qui a sorti l'étude
montrant ça. le permafros qui est en
train de fondre sortant les germes de
l'entraxe
de la greppe espagnole. Donc comme on
disait au départ, nous sommes dans un
état écologique très grave.
Il faut réagir et on sait pas si on n
pas dépassé les effets de seuil.
Donc faut agir aujourd'hui. On fait quoi
? Je vous donne ma baguette magique.
Demain, vous avez plein pouvoir d'un
d'un d'une toute petite province qui
s'appelle la France.
Vous faites quoi ?
Euh,
vous dites "Voilà, j'ai j'ai 150 têtes
nucléaires, si on ne se calme pas, je
préfère avoir la main sur mon destin. Je
crame tout le monde. Je fais quoi Alors,
c'est vraiment une autre façon de
penser, hein. Donc bon, un, il faut
remettre les services rendus par les
écosystèmes vivants. Ils sont à la base
des cycles du carbone, de l'eau, de
l'oxygène, de tout et du confort de du
maintien des du confort thermique et
cetera, de notre nourriture, de tout
donc des sols. Donc un pour cette
raison, on refait de la on fait de la ce
qu'on appelle les infrastructures vertes
et bleues partout
avec la fin de
on déjà dans les villes on ne construit
plus une seule station d'épuration sauf
dans les lieux où on peut pas mettre de
jardin d'épuration mais c'est très rare
parce qu'ils sont béton nuis en plus
donc ils ils forment des bassins
étanches. On met des jardins de pluie
pour l'infiltration des autres de pluies
par contre là, partout là où on peut. Et
ça c'est la ça amène de la biodiversité.
On débétonne un maximum les friches
industrielles que d'ailleurs plein de de
d'industriels ne ne lè pas parce qu'ils
ont la trouille des effets des
assurances justement sur la sécurité,
l'usage et cetera. Donc on a on a un
blocage des friches industrielles, on
les met en dépollution directe par les
végétaux et on exploite. D'ailleurs, ça
fait des ça fait plein de filières
biochimiques euh parce que les plantes
qui peuvent dépolluer ces sols, elles
ont elles développent des des
particularités très particulières, très
fortes, qui leur permet de d'être, c'est
une française qui a montré ça, qui leur
permet d'être des catalyseurs chimiques,
médecine, cosmétique, enfin des des
grosses filières et et en en bio quoi,
enfin en en vivant, on va dire. Et euh
et donc voilà donc ville urbanisme
écologique partout. Et pourquoi ? Parce
que ça fait du lien social et on a
besoin de sens dans nos sociétés. On a
besoin de nouveau se rencontrer, sinon
on passera pas les crises.
Euh et puis ça évite de mettre les
climatiseurs et cetera. Euh agriculture,
passage massif à l'agroécologie
et financement de la transition qui dure
à peu près 2 à 3 ans chez les
agriculteurs et avec et agroécologie et
agroforesterie. C'est-à-dire que on
remet des ha, on remet des plantations
d'arbres pour le bois aussi d'ailleurs
pour stabiliser les sols pour un tas de
je vais pas rentrer dans le technique.
On
on met le on applique en fait la
philosophie permaculturelle notamment à
l'agriculture maréchère et aux villes
parce qu'en fait c'est une philosophie
la permaculture au niveau des
équipements industriels.
On facilite les programmes juridiques,
les structures juridiques pour permettre
aux habitants de devenir coopérateurs de
leurs infrastructures de biens
d'équipement comme l'Allemagne l'a fait
par exemple pour les infrastructures
énergétiques. Ce qui fait que elle a été
pionnière des énergies renouvelables
dans les années 2000. pas des grands
majors mais des citoyens et des villes.
Elle a créé 750 coopératives municipales
en 10 ans, en moins de 10 ans. Et c'est
comme ça qu'elle a été pionnière dans
les énergies renouvelables. Plus de la
moitié de cette électricité a été
produite par les habitants en réalité et
il redistribuaient la valeur. Mais on
fait la même chose pour la voiture où on
a des systèmes qui aujourd'hui
permettent non seulement de enfin la
voiture, les biens d'équipement
électroménagés et cetera où les
fabricants investissent avec les usagers
sur des systèmes en fait un peu comme le
fairphone mais modulaire interopérable
où en fait on permet de réutiliser mais
là je pardon je vais perdre vos
téléspectateurs donc je vais arrêter
peut-être permet Non non non, si je pas
c'est que ça va.
On permet on permet de réutiliser les
composants en cycle fermé.
Voyez par exemple les ordinateurs. Tant
que c'était les constructeurs, les
ordinateurs coûtaient très cher. À
partir du moment où on a fait les
composant interopérable,
en fait les assembleurs ont pris le
marché et l'ordinateur est devenu très
peu cher. Par contre, massification,
enfin consommation de masse des
ordinateurs. Le problème c'est que les
assembleurs, les DL, les compagnies ne
récupèrent jamais leurs ordinateurs.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils en transfèrent
la propriété. On on on serait usager de
nos biens d'équipement. Conçu comme ça
de façon interopérable, modulaire, les
fabricant récupère les les le bien
d'équipement mais ça marche pour tout et
ils peuvent réutiliser les composants et
les remettre et en mettre remettre les
machines nouvelles en fait dans le
circuit. Et ça c'est ça permet des
économies de matière de folie. Même si
vous avez votre objet personnel, c'est
je vous dis c'était en 15 entre 15 et
16. Si en plus vous êtes sur des parcs
mutualisés comme la voiture parce que la
voiture est immobile 93 % de son temps
de vie en fait et bien alors là vous
multipliez par un autre facteur qui est
celui de la mutualisation qui est de 3 à
15 selon les études. Donc donc vous
faites voilà facteur 16 multiplié par 3
à 15. Vous voyez, on est déjà des
facteurs 60
enfin et euh et quand vous utilisez en
plus d'autres techniques comme le
biomimétisme, vous diminuez les
compositions composants métalliques.
Donc on a encore d'autres facteurs.
C'est une innovation vraiment de
rupture.
Mais le problème c'est que ça c'est un
réseau et ça reforme des monopoles, ce
dont on parlait tout à l'heure. Et c'est
comme ça que Rang Zerox par exemple qui
a fait ça il y a 4 dans les années 90.
Aujourd'hui, plus personne ne veut ne
veut signer un contrat avec parce qu'il
sont devenus les contrats sont devenus
léonants. Donc, il faut au de la
concurrence au coposéder
avec les fabricants et les usagers ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure, ces usines
d'assemblage au niveau local. Voilà.
Donc facilitation des structures
juridiques coopératives, euh une vraie
euh diffusion de la culture de l'usage
de de la de auprès des industriels de de
l'interopérabilité et cetera et un un
vrai euh une vraie euh possibilité pour
les villes de proposer aux villes enfin
de proposer à leurs habitants de devenir
à la fois les investisseurs de leur
voiture, d'avoir leur voiture, leur éle
éleectroménager leur smartphone en étant
investisseur en leur donnant les emplois
parce que c'est des emplois non
délocalisables, c'est de l'assemblage et
en plus en en en leur donnant en plus
accès à l'innovation parce que
l'innovation vient majoritairement des
usagers. Donc ça ouvre si vous voulez le
les cas qu'on a. On voit bien que euh
l'innovation est incroyable. Incroyable
parce que elle n'est plus elle n'est
plus faite en chambre fermée chez des
euh chez les industriels qui ne savent
pas innover par essence. Voilà.
Question internet. Comment lutter
comment lutter contre le green washing
si elle s'approprie le langage de
l'écologie ? Comment se démarquer pour
être écouté ?
C'est une vraie question. Euh
Cyprien,
c'est-à-dire que en effet le mot
transition est repris. Développement
durable, n'en parlons pas.
Voilà.
En même temps, moi j'ai envie de me
réapproprier les mots. C'est pour ça que
j'ai appelé ça économie, même si je suis
pas économiste. Les mots de qu'on nous a
piqué quand même.
C'est-à-dire que franchement économie
c'est un très bon mot.
On les a pas piqué, on les a travestis
mais on nous a piqué dans dans le sens
commun. C'est-à-dire, on nous a piqué le
on qui est. Je déteste en plus quand les
gens font ça. Là, je le fais, je suis
désolée. Mais le le l'usage enfin
comment on appelle économie dans notre
société ? Enfin, économie, ça veut dire
quoi ? Gestion de la maison et de la
maisonnée.
Or, ce qu'on appelle économie
aujourd'hui est un pillage. On s'en rend
compte maintenant, c'est une
destruction.
Donc on doit se réapproprier le mot
économie pour dire non non, vous n'êtes
pas des économistes. Est-ce que vous
gérez la maison et la maisonnée ? Je ne
crois pas. Vous voyez, je pense ça. Je
pense qu'on doit se réapproprier le mot
et au contraire dire prouvez-moi que
vous êtes un économiste
vu le sens du mot.
Parce que c'est grave ce qui nous
arrive. De la même façon, on parle de
démocratie
alors qu'on sait qu'on est en
gouvernement représentatif
et qu'en 1789 justement on n' pas voulu
de la démocratie
des mos. Donc on croit que c'est
toujours le peuple qui gouverne. Non, on
est en gouvernement représentatif. C'est
très intéressant. C'est une forme de
gouvernance comme comme d'autres. Mais
utilisons les bons mots et si on veut de
la démocratie, alors réclamons
qu'est-ce que c'est la démocratie ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est le gouvernement
représentatif ? Il faut remettre en fait
les acteurs qui prennent des mots, qui
s'approprient les mots je suis
économiste, je suis un démocrate en
disant "Prouvez-le-moi". Parce que c'est
pas ça que veut dire ce mot.
Le green washing. Euh vous avez des
exemples ?
Bah du green washing. Du green washing.
Oui, il y a plein de fausses bonnes
idées et puis parfois ce green washing
il est parfois ce green washing il est
inconscient. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
gens qui croient vraiment puis faire
quelque chose de bien puis en fait non.
Ça moi c'est ça a été l'origine de ma
recherche. C'était pour discriminer
justement ceux qui produisaient vraiment
les les plusvalues qu'on recherchait et
ceux qui les produisaient pas en toute
en toute sincérité. Après, il y a le
green washing conscient, le social
washing conscient. Et oui, là c'est
c'est terrible. Enfin des exemples, ça
fait longtemps que je m'énerve plus avec
ça, mais
euh je sais pas. Oui, bah oui, les 44
écologiques par exemple, c'est drôle ou
euh c'est ou même la la vo enfin tout ce
qui la voiture électrique la voiture
électrique qui serait écologique
aujourd'hui non. Aujourd'hui non parce
qu'on est sur des telle qu'elle est
commercialisée aujourd'hui on se met pas
en économie d'usage la voiture peut pas
être écologique euh parce que alors elle
va être plus écologique sur les
pollutions atmosphériques. Oui, ça c'est
vrai. Ça c'est vrai.
Elle va C'est une pollution qui est
transférée ailleurs.
Ah non non non. sur la pollution
atmosphérique dans la rue, ça c'est
vrai. Sur la pollution par le bruit, ça
c'est vrai.
là où elle est fabriquée, si on est dans
les systèmes traditionnels,
non seulement c'est une catastrophe
sociale, écologique,
économique, enfin complète pour les pays
qui qui sont dans dans notamment les
pays où on extrait les matières
premières, mais en plus c'est pas du
tout du rap puisqu'on est sur des métaux
qu'on appelle les terrars, même si tous
ne sont pas des terrars et que et que et
que aujourd'hui on est incapable dans le
même modèle économique, donc de
transfert de la propriété, de pouvoir
assurer la voiture demain et n'importe
quoi, vos ordinateurs, internet et
cetera. Je veux dire très très vite là,
on va pouvoir l'assurer à qu'à une très
une grande minorité de la population.
Donc enfin une petite pardon, une petite
petite minorité de la population. Donc
c'est ces modèles économiques si vous
voulez. Le problème du métal. Le métal
ça vient des étoiles. Ça a été
synthétisé dans les étoiles. D'accord.
Ça ça c'est c'est indestructible métal.
Ça se disperse. Mais c'est
indestructible.
La plupart des métaux peuvent être
réutilisés
et à partir du moment où on conçoit les
objet pour pouvoir réutiliser les
composants et puis le le de de mais que
le fabricant enfin c'est les modèles
économiques dont je vous parlais que le
fabricant en fait récupère
les composants pour les réutiliser dans
les dans les nouvelles machines. Ça
c'est vraiment fondamental.
Autre question d'internet, comment
combattualisation
comment combattre alors les géants et
les lobby de l'agrochimie ?
On n'y arrivera pas à les combattre.
Il faut imposer un autre modèle parce
que le modèle qu'on propose est beaucoup
plus efficace.
Pourquoi imposer ? imposer dans la
culture et dans la
proposer alors
oui pardon imposer comme une normalité
dans le sens où oui pas imposé vous avez
raison prop en fait on a le problème on
on doit disrupter les imaginaires
aujourd'hui.
C'est dire quoi disrupter ?
C'est-à-dire, on doit provoquer une
vraie rupture des imaginaires ou euh
ce que vous me disiez tout à l'heure,
bisou nours euh le vivant ça peut pas
être efficace, mais c'est c'est
tellement joli. J'ai pas dit que le
vivant était pas efficace. C'est par
contre bisou nours gour, on entend
beaucoup sur pense. C'est ce qu'on pense
et c'est ce que notre culture pense. Et
donc on doit vraiment à ce niveau-là
faire en sorte que dans notre culture
elle rompe avec ça et qu'on ait les
indicateur qui montrent cette efficience
et qui font que les acteurs non
seulement voudront manger ça, verront
qu'il est plus rentable d'investir
là-dedans en fait et pas les pas les
acteurs liés aux gros extracteurs. On a
un tas d'acteurs intermédiaires
qui peuvent aider vraiment c'est eux qui
vont aider à la transition.
Question internet. Elle vide de quoi
cette dame ? Elle ne fait elle n'a fait
qu'un livre et un film. D'où vient son
financement ? C'est un vrai problème.
J'ai j'ai beaucoup vécu de mon écriture.
J'ai quand j'ai pas pu quand les
universités au départ ont pas compris ma
recherche, j'ai monté ma boîte. Donc, je
vis du conseil aux organisations, aux
territoires et là je suis contente parce
que on est en train de monter une chair,
je vous dis et j'espère enfin avoir le
véhicule. C'est pour ça aussi que je
réponds pas aux mails, je réponds pas
aux sollicitations parce que j'en ai
trop en fait et que je dois vivre. Donc
il y a Non, non, j'ai aucun truc de
rien.
En ce moment,
c'est que dalle.
Ouais.
Ouais. que que dalle plus proche du RSA
ou que dalle comme
je sais pas c'est ben c'est Ouais c'est
c'est très peu euh là par exemple je
viens de faire une grosse étude pour
l'agence spatiale européenne.
Euh ça c'est ça ça fait du bien quoi.
Donc
ben une étude comme ça pour euh euh
c'est un marché public donc je peux le
dire c'était c'est 80000 € à peu près
pour pour réussir à faire dans toute une
de leurs structures un commun justement
en fait un commun d'innovation
sur combien de temps
sur
ça dure entre le premier rendez-vous et
le moment où vous où vous vous rendez
l'étude. Là ça a été assez rapide
d'ailleurs. C'était 6 8 mois mais une
petite comme ça vous enfin vous en avez
Ouais c'est voilà et puis il faut en
fait c'est des acteurs qui ont lu
l'économie symbique qui sont convaincus
parce que sinon
mais 80000 € mais on est à trois dessus.
Ouais bah oui.
Donc et avec les charges parce que je
suis entrepreneuse donc vous divisez ça
par 2 et demi en fait.
Alors autre question et l'énergie dans
tout ça on garde le nucléaire pour
l'interrogation.
Alors non surtout pas. Ce premier
principe euh qui est le s'inscrire dans
les cycles biogéochimiques et
physiologiques de la planète, le
nucléaire ne s'inscrit pas dans nos nos
cycles physiologiques. Il est mutagène
et il est très très dangereux et en fait
non, on non il y a une vraie la
transition énergétique est vue
complètement différemment. D'abord les
écosystèmes vivants, l'usage des
écosystèmes vivants fait permet vraiment
euh à diminue
énormément la consommation d'énergie là
où c'est utilisé. C'est très intéressant
parce par exemple parce que les
l'agroécologie au niveau mondial quand
quand les recherches ont commencé
dessus, c'était une commande des États
et c'était face à la crise pétrolière.
fallait trouver un moyen de se de
diminuer la dépendance du de de
l'agriculture au pétrole et finalement
donc c'était un des fondements et et en
fait c'est les pratiques agroécologiques
qui qui sont remontées comme parmi les
plus efficaces le au niveau de de la la
mutualisation et les synergies produites
en fait font que on a des vraies
ruptures aussi au niveau de la
consommation énergétique. Ça c'est des
choses qui sont pas vu. Vous voyez par
exemple dans les dans les programmes de
bâtiments et cetera, on pense tout de
suite isolation
mais en fait la mutualisation d'un tas
d'espace est extrêmement efficace et et
en fait la mutualisation vous augmente
le nombre de services. C'est pas tant
qu'elle est vécue comme une contrainte,
ça marche pas. tant qu'elle est vécue
comme bien avoir quelque chose que je ne
pourrais pas m'offrir seul mais
mutualiser en fait j'ai un confort et de
vie supérieur et en fait une
consommation énergétique inférieure
parce que vous mutualisez avec parfois
20 30 40 personnes. C'est dingue.
Question d'exo
estelle est-elle une adepte de la pensée
de Pierre Rabi ?
Non.
Pourquoi ? Euh j'aime beaucoup Pierre
Abi parce que je trouve que il a
vraiment aidé à la à la conscientisation
des choses. Euh son mouvement colibri
est incroyable. C'est quand même le
mouvement le plus distribué, le plus
actif qu'on est aujourd'hui. Euh mais
euh il a fait d'une technique une
idéologie et moi ça j'ai du mal. Donc
l'agroécologie en a fait une idéologie
et euh et donc moi ça ça vraiment je
voilà c'est pour moi c'est j'ai du mal
avec ça, je peux pas. Et puis euh il a
toujours une vision négative de l'humain
en fait parce que finalement
quand il parle d'agroécologie et il donc
on est dans des dans des sols très
caillouux qui sont redevenus mais des
oasis et on serait mais on a toujours le
le discours de l'homme qui fait
tellement mal à la planète alors que des
soles viennent d'être régénéré alors que
l'action concrète son action concrète a
au contraire de remettre de la vie. Donc
il y a cette toujours cette vision d'un
être humain négatif pour la planète que
je sens encore chez Pierre Abi.
Peut-être à tort ou à raison mais et
alors que voilà alors que moi c'est
vraiment ça que m'a appris l'économie
symbiotique, c'est que en fait l'être
humain peut être positif pour sa planète
quoi. On n'est pas des maudits, on n'est
pas l'espèce maudite. Non non, on peut
être positif pour les êtres vivants qui
nous entourent. un un jardin d'épuration
à côté duquel je vivais
euh et bien j'avais des martin pêcheurs,
j'avais des martins pêcheurs et c'était
à côté de Paris.
Très bien toutes ces idées, mais est-ce
que vous pensez que les oligarques de
Monsanto et compagnie seront d'accord
pour rendre les armes et perdre le lead
?
Bien sûr que non.
Il y a une grande guerre en ce moment.
On perd, on gagne culturellement, y
compris dans les industries. On perd sur
toutes les réglementations,
sur tous les lobbyes.
Est-ce que j'ai ma réponse est
suffisante ? Bien sûr que non.
Mais il faut il faut continuer à se
battre mais pas avec les mêmes armes.
Est-ce que vous avez des conflits
d'intérêt ?
Pour l'instant non.
Même dans la chair que je veux montrer,
je ne veux pas en avoir. C'est-à-dire
que j'ai aucun problème pour les grandes
industries, mais je veux pas qu'elle
soit seule, hein. Je veux monter avec ma
communauté, c'est-à-dire les acteurs de
l'économie régénérative qui sont très
nombreux et qui peuvent parfois être
très gros. Et deux, s'il y a des géants,
mais il faut qu'il y ait plusieurs
géants. Vous connaissez le compte du
petit ailleur ?
Oui, mais non. J'adore ce compte à cause
de ça en fait. Le petit ailleur doit
aller tuer le géant dans la forêt. Les
géants dans la forêt en fait, il les met
sous l'arbre et se tue entre eux. Et je
pense que aujourd'hui, on a besoin
d'argent pour faire la transition. Il y
a des vraies industries qui veulent la
faire. C'est difficile pour elle. Il
faut qu'elle puisse innover à certains
endroits et on a besoin nous de pour
passer à l'échelle de l'argent de ces
industries, mais elles ne doivent pas
prendre notre gouvernance.
Question d'Internet. Faudrait-il une
dictature fondée sur l'écologie ?
Jamais.
Jamais. Pourquoi ? Est-ce que la
dictature elle est elle est elle est par
essence oligarque ?
Qui a qui aujourd'hui depuis de quels
sont les acteurs qui ont qui ont réagi
qui nous apportent aujourd'hui des des
solutions ? Enfin, j'aime pas ce mot
mais une vraie alternative,
c'est les associations, c'est les
citoyens, c'est les entrepreneurs, c'est
les ma
Donc surtout pas et pas et de toute
façon même
je non je non.
Comment vous percevez le pouvoir
politique ? Comment vous percevez le
pouvoir Macron ? Est-ce que c'est de
l'opportunisme écologique ? C'est on va
prendre le modèle Hidalgo,
c'est de l'opportunisme ou pas ? Est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il y a un politique
qui incarne tout ça ? Est-ce qu'il y a
un courant politique qui peut mettre sur
le la table et d'une façon
opérationnelle la chose ? Est-ce que
vous avez identifié un porteur d'idées ?
Je pense que le politique nationale est
bloqué aujourd'hui. Pourquoi ? parce que
la vraie le vrai pouvoir est économique,
hein,
et il est régi par ce qui fait le ce qui
fonde le politique. En fait, l'outil du
un des gros outils du politique, c'est
la loi. OK. Qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui
le volet de la loi qui correspond à
l'économique ? C'est la réglementation.
En fait, c'est ça qui régit l'économique
productif
et euh et je vous dis sur tout ça, on
perd partout. Or aujourd'hui, vous avez
trois grands centres réglementaires ou
économ de de législation d'accord
économique en en tout cas dans
l'Occident. Vous avez le Sénat
américain, vous avez l'Union européenne
et l'OMC. En gros, vous avez à côté de
ça une concentration du pouvoir
économique tel que la dernière étude
qu'on a qui date d'il y a 13 ans, enfin
à ma connaissance qui date de 2007
avrant les grandes concentrations qu'on
a encore eu après 2008 montre que sur
les 43000
multinationales qu'on avait dans le
monde à l'époque, on en avait 750 qui
euh qui Oui, c'est ça. 750 qui
contrôlait he par le jeu des chaises au
conseil d'administration donc contrôlait
contrôlait les décisions des des 43000
autres de 80 c'est ça 80 % des 43000
autres et 140 40 % c'est-à-dire qu'on
est dans une hyper concentration et du
pouvoir économique
et de la décision politique sur la loi
c'est devenu des autoroutes. Moi, j'ai
commencé ma carrière par le lobby pour
les agriculteurs biologiques. Autant
vous dire qu'on était 5 dans un bureau
de 25 m² à tous fumé parce qu'à l'époque
c'était c'était autorisé stressé comme
des malades av à envoyer les fax à la
main. En plus à l'époque, je me souviens
quand on avait le programme, on a eu le
programmateur de fax, c'était la
libération. On navait pas encore ça
réagissait pas encore au mail. Donc
c'est pour vous dire vous voyez le voilà
nous ça s'est amélioré mais en gros vous
avez combien de lobbyistes de notre
domaine à Bruxelles par rapport aux 2000
3000 lobbyistes industriels ? Donc par
mois
ils sont Oui voilà. Ah oui, c'est
hallucinant les les Je me souviens d'un
rendez-vous justement parce que c'est
beaucoup les avocats et je me suis dit
mais mon dieu mais je me suis trompée de
métier. La nana elle avait un un diamant
gros comme ça. Maintenant il se cachent
maintenant il se cachent ils se cachent,
ils évitent ça. Maintenant ils portent
des baskets à 900 € qui coûte qui coûte
30 € fait par la mafia italienne.
Ou mais enfin voilà. Et donc si vous
voulez, pour revenir à notre sujet, on
on a on a des autoroutes pour le lobby
aujourd'hui. C'est même très dangereux
en fait d'y aller et en plus on a un
effet en fait d'adaptation très très
fort. C'est-à-dire que quand on arrive,
moi j'avais j'avais fait le l'affaire du
purin d'orti en 2006, c'était sorti de
mon blog et d'un autre blog et on avait
réussi à vraiment, j'avais jamais vu ça,
on avait réussi vraiment à à à
comment dire à à faire changer la loi en
quelques semaines et euh et à faire
vriller les choses en fait parce que ils
connaissaient pas ça. C'était c'était
par les blogs, c'était très nouveau, ils
avaient pas vu venir en fait et et
bien tr quoi de mois après, ça a été
refait d'une façon beaucoup plus
subtile, donc beaucoup moins
communicable pour nous dans une autre
loi.
Vous voyez ? Donc en fait, il y a une
adaptation permanente. On perd pour moi
aujourd'hui hein. Aujourd'hui avec le la
concentration des pouvoirs qu'on a, on
perd systématiquement. Donc en fait, il
faut vraiment emmener du côté des
investissements. Du côté des
investissements et là ça ça bouge.
Un courant politique en particulier.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le par
exemple Europe écologie les verts, c'est
que des apparati qui se placent là et
qui qui blablade sur autour de
l'écologie pour rayonner mais quand même
garder leur statut de politique où
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment encore des
moines bénédictins qui pensent à
l'intérêt général, qui pensent à
la terre, à notre biotope ? Est-ce qu'il
y a vraiment euh parce qu'en général on
les repère bien ce ce les mo les moines
bénédicins ils gagnent pas un radis. Non
mais vous me faites rire parce que vous
êtes de nouveau dans les moines
bénédictins et cetera. Le sacrifice on
doit sortir de cette notion de
sacrifice.
Désolé, j'étais élevé par les jésuites.
On doit Oui, mais moi j'étais élevé par
les dominicaines. On a on doit sortir de
cette notion de sacrifice parce que
parce que justement ça va ça va à
l'encontre de ce qui est vraiment
l'écologie. En fait, quand vous regardez
ce qui se passe, ça nous amène une
économie. D'ailleurs, Galgiro vient de
le dire, de surabondance
et et on a du mal à penser ça. En fait,
ça nous amène des opportunités
économiques, sociales,
individuelles incroyable. Incroyable.
Mais parce qu'on a toujours cette vision
de de l'écologie comme un sacrifice. On
on l'a on l'a même écologistes, on a on
a quand vous entendez le le discours
majoritaire écologiste, il est toujours
à se comparer au monde d'avant.
C'est-à-dire que il va toujours parler
de la contrainte. Moins que on va perdre
du confort, on va Mais c'est pas en plus
c'est pas vrai. Moi je vis d'un mode
écologique depuis 20 ans. Alors je
progresse hein parce que c'est pas
facile au départ. Mais mais mais en fait
je remplacé la surconsommation par la
surcréation. Je je enfin j'ai un mode de
vie beaucoup plus agréable que la enfin
que avant en tout cas et que je pense la
plupart des gens en fait grâce à ça.
Donc et c'est un monde d'opportunités
incroyable social, économique comme je
disais. Donc mais on est toujours à se
comparer à l'ancien et et alors j'aime
beaucoup le livre de Francesco Alberoni,
le choc amoureux.
Le choc amoureux, il montre en fait que
un mouvement social procède comme un
inamorento, un un un tomber en amour,
hein, je sais plus comment on dit en
français.
Enfin, tomber amoureux. Oui, voilà.
tomber amoureux euh euh entre deux
personnes et parce que en fait ça quand
vous tombez amoureux en fait ça ça
d'abord vous trouvez chez l'autre des
manques enfin des des réponses à des
manques, un besoin vous aviez envie de
changer en fait et tout à coup les
choses le permettent. Il y a il y a il y
a une fascination, il y a un éclat qui
se produit et enfin bon bref, je vais
pas vous raconter le bouquin, il compare
ça et mais comment vous pouvez tomber
amoureux d'une femme qui vous parlerait
toujours de son ancien amant ?
pas possible, on doit rompre avec ça.
On a un autre imaginaire à proposer.
Il y a une chose dont je suis convaincu,
c'est que c'est clair qu'on laissera pas
une terre comme on l'a reçu.
Vous avez des enfants ?
Oui, j'en ai trois.
Vous les avez fait avant ou après avoir
pris conscience que c'était compliqué ?
Euh non, j'ai ben moi j'ai fait mes
études pour ça. Je suis tombée dans la
marmite très très tôt. Euh donc non,
tout après. Oui, mais il y en a il y a
quand même après le deuxième, j'ai
j'avais lu des études des études
géologiques et notamment sur enfin
voilà. de la crise qui nous ressemble
plus, c'est la crise du précambrien. 80
plus de 95 % de la vie sur terre a
disparu et même des structures de vie
sur terre ont disparu, ce qui n s'est
jamais produit dans autrees crise
biologique. Et nous, on va beaucoup plus
vite et on est à peu près au même enfin
on est à peu près les mêmes causes.
C'était aussi une cause carbonée.
C'est naturel, ça va remettre la balance
à zéro.
Euh ouais, enfin moi je vous savez moi
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien vivre sur
cette terre.
J'ai juste j'ai juste envie de continuer
à vivre là et avec mes enfants quoi.
Donc mais quand j'ai vu ça là, j'ai
compris que oui, on pouvait vraiment
changer les équilibres écologiques
globaux et que qu'on pouvait disparaître
et ça se rapasse autour d'une tasse de
thé. là vraiment vraiment et là bon sang
euh là j'ai pleuré pendant 3 semaines
d'avoir fait mes deux premiers enfants
et puis vous savez la vie fait que comme
je voulais pas d'un en fait c'était un
deuxième mariage et je voulais pas d'un
enfant unique et bien mais on en a fait
un deuxième donc un troisè
la vie vous rattrape
pas moi c'est le mon cas en tout cas
le pense question de Pierre pense-t-elle
que nous avons les capacités de réaliser
ces idées dans notre société
individuelle dualiste.
Alors, j'en suis persuadée parce que un
tout existe déjà. Moi, je suis partie
que de l'existant. J'ai montré que les
principes et les lois et comment ça
pouvait rentrer en synergie. Donc, la
puissance potentielle du truc. Donc, je
ne suis partie que de l'existence. Et ça
a 5 plus de 50 ans cette histoire. Donc,
on a les deux générations nécessaires au
changement derrière nous. Donc, c'est
partout dans tous les pays, dans partout
où vous habitez, vous avez des acteurs
de ce type. Voilà. Donc les mères sont
en train de prendre conscience, donc on
va pouvoir avoir des choses et mais il
faut quand même accélérer, ça c'est sûr
hein, ça ça il faut il faut s'y mettre
maintenant. Mais non mais le dernier
rapport de 15°gr quand même hein, c'est
très c'était très important que le 15°gr
soit remis au goût du jour. C'était ce
qui avait été demandé. Enfin bon bref
dit
donc en fait bon le 15 degrés
ici ont des surcnes cures. D'accord. On
a le temps,
on on est là pour on a le temps.
On a longtemps parlé du 2 degr celus. En
fait, le 2 degr CUS n'était pas un
consensus scientifique, il était un
consensus politique
et euh où on disait que en effet à
partir de les scientifiques disent qu'à
partir de 2 degrés, on sait vraiment pas
que enfin on a des effets euh
probablement de de seuil qui v nous
emmène à 4 6 8°gr. C'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'il viennent de rappeler eux et donc
le 2 degrés n'était a été un consensus
politique. Et à Copenhague en 2009, moi
je suivais les négociations
pour pour des journaux internet
d'ailleurs. Et et bien on a eu une
manifestation énorme dans le centre des
négociations des des pays insulaires les
plus enfin les pays les plus menacés par
le changement climatique insulaire,
subsaharien et cetera pour imposer le
pour demander le 1,5°gr qu'ils n'ont pas
eu. La COP 21 grâce notamment au
Commonwealth, a permis de remettre le
1,5°gr sur la table et ça c'est très
important parce que la différence donc
du coup on a eu un rapport du GC sur le
1,5°
et on voit qui est paru fin 2018 et on
voit que la différence entre d'abord le
1,5° est toujours tenable. Il faut il
faut se manier mais il est toujours
tenable et la différence des dégâts
entre 1,5° 2° est absolument
gigantesque. Et donc le 1,5°
euh la présidente du rapport Valérie
Massonelmot dit chaque mois compte.
Chaque mois compte. Et c'est très bien
qu'un qu'une pandémie comme le Covid par
exemple nous oblige à réfléchir
aujourd'hui parce que parce que on a des
ruptures comme ça qui nous permettre de
de s'exprimer sur ces choses-là, de
réfléchir dans une dans une dans un choc
collectif.
De elle dit en fait enfin le rapport
montre combien en effet les techniques
régénératives vont être très importantes
et qu'ensuite 80 % des solutions sont
locales et dépendent d'une gouvernance
collaborative.
On ne doit pas attendre.
Les solutions les plus Ça veut dire quoi
ça ? C'est que les solutions les plus
efficaces viennent de nos territoires et
donc de notre capacité d'agir et
d'échelle.
C'est très très important ça. On est
formaté devant un problème aussi grand
de demander évidemment au plus grand, au
plus puissant et cetera de prendre en
charge le problème mais non seulement
concrètement ils le prennent pas en
charge,
continue de voter.
Ça c'est important de continuer de voter
hein parce que quand on voit quand on a
un Paul Sonaro par exemple, ça change
les choses aussi hein. Euh donc il vaut
mieux voter. Mais non seulement ils ne
prennent pas en compte le problème, mais
en plus les solutions parmi les 80 % des
solutions viendront du local sont dans
le local.
Question de Youfolk qui est revenue très
en forme.
Elle serait prête à conseiller Monsanto
?
Bah non, ne serait-ce que pour des
raisons financières. Vous avez vu ce qu'
vous avez vu l'aventure de l'aventure de
Bayer depuis qu'il a il est devenu euh
depuis qu'il est devenu il a acheté
Monso. Son son son le cours de Bayer,
elle lui a coûté plus cher que le le
prix le il est il est aussi du moins
côté que le prix qu'il a acheté Monso.
Ça se faire refiler la patate
empoisonné.
Et Monso, attention parce qu'il partent
sur la data là sur
sur l'agroécologie, la data et cetera.
Vous avez compris la question ? Oui oui
non mais c'est très Non mais il faut le
alors ça peut-être que les gens savent
pas mais Monsu part sur la data, la
possession des datas, l'agroécologie.
Alors en plus en plus il se trouve que
non non mais en plus il se trouve qu'en
effet le roundup le roundup est
aujourd'hui appelé par les par les
agroécologues eux-mêmes enfin les
paysans agroécologistes même le 4e
pilier de l'agroécologie. Oui, oui, vous
allez dans
pas de diffamation des sources,
attention he ter Ah, j'adore ce
magazine, moi je suis agronome au départ
ils ont TCS technique technique
culturale simplifiée. Voilà, c'est c'est
un magazine enfin c'est un magazine
d'agriculteurs monté Oui. Oui. un
magazine monté par les agriculteurs pour
les agriculteurs en agroécologie et où
justement ben un je crois que c'était le
fondateur d'ailleurs qui avait écrit cet
article qui dit qui posait la question
le glyphosate
3e oui 3e pilier de non 4e pilier de
l'agroécologie parce que aujourd'hui en
fait les les
le temps de la transition
les agriculteurs agroécologistes ont
encore besoin d'un d'un herbicide total
en fait ça peut être résolu avec la
technicité ça monte et les les
agriculteurs les plus techniques n'en
ont plus besoin enfin et mais du coup
Monsanto du coup Monsanto se fait la
promotion de l'agroécologie mais il fait
aussi la la promotion de l'agriculture
de précision qui va donc l'agriculture
de précision c'est un tracteur bourré de
capteurs
et sur la disponibilité des enfin en eau
machin et cetera, enfin les ravageurs
ceci et qui prend la data qui vous
permet en effet de de de
prévenir des attaque de ravageur et
cetera mais en en en
possédant toute la data des
agriculteurs. Ce qui fait que là déjà on
a on a des agriculteurs en Amérique du
Nord qui se sont battu contre Monsanto
parce que ils n'avait plus aucune aucune
enfin ils étaient non seulement enfin un
fournisseur quand même important mais en
plus qui pouvaient prévoir leur
rendement, leurs chiffres d'affaires,
leur machin qui les prenait pied point
lié. Non surtout pas.
Question question alors qui est sortie
de son contexte. À mon avis, ça doit
être une question sur les politiques et
sur le changement de système. Quelles
sont nos armes ?
Nos armes, c'est quoi ? C'est notre
portefeuille. Nos armes, c'est quoi ?
C'est c'est notre bulletin de vote. Nos
armes, c'est quoi ? C'est une fourge
bien pointue ?
Non, surtout pas.
la violence et la force des faibles.
Non, je pense que justement on doit
vraiment casser avec
cette idée que cette culture du chef,
cette culture de la peur parce que quand
une pop quand vous avez peur de
l'humain, si vous avez peur de l'humain,
la masse vous fait peur. Vous dites
"Mais il faut un chef pour pouvoir
contrôler cette masse
et plus vous plus il sera dominant." On
le voit très bien avec Trump.
et bien plus il sera dominant, plus en
fait il vous rassurera
et et donc plus il vous dominera, plus
il vous rassurera et et il y a une
tendance à élire ce genre de personne.
Donc voilà. Donc il faut absolument
rompre avec la peur la peur de de
l'humain. La peur de l'humain. Donc pour
moi, il est extrêmement important de
nouer avec un truc qui paraît
complètement bisounance que les journaux
n'aiment pas, que les les par tradition
les journalistes, personne n'aime ça,
les intellectuels et cetera avec la pas
ici
la
avec la part belle de l'humain. Il y a
un truc qui est assez incroyable dans
dans l'économie symbique, c'est elle
montre en fait que le beau peut être
puissant, le doux peut être efficace et
viceversa. C'est ça qui est fou et on
n'est pas du tout habitué à ça en
réalité. On le rejette. Pour nous, ce
qui est beau, ça peut pas être efficace.
Ce qui est doux, ça peut pas être
puissant. Or, en fait, on on le voit
d'ailleurs avec la vie, elle est
extrêmement puissante. Faut voir quand
même ce qu'elle a fait de la terre.
C'est mal fait private joke et il y a
que moi qui suis à l'écran parce que
j'ai mon alors je donne le private joke.
J'ai mon réalisateur qui est beau et
puissant à ma droite et qui est tout
doux.
Donc il faut croire en ça. Il faut
renverser cette vision là. Sinon sinon
on voilà cette peur de l'humain. Il faut
savoir exactement ce qu'on est capable
de faire. Je pense que le 20e siècle
avec la quantité de génocide en plus
qu'on a fait au 20e siècle le montre
très très bien. Mais il ne faut pas
s'arrêter là-dessus. Il faut voir
l'autre potentiel que l'on a. Ça c'est
très important de nourrir ça. Ensuite
donc ça c'est essentiel et ça c'est ça
c'est le en fait je pense que c'est
presque le plus difficile. Là vous en
vous prenez vous en prenez plein la
figure quand vous faites ça.
Alors ensuite c'est en effet euh les
politiques municipaux les les le local
là les municipales c'est extrêmement
important. Il faut challenger les maires
sur ce qu'ils vont vous faire
localement. Les régies alimentaires, les
régies de l'eau, les régies internet.
Tout ça c'est possible. Tout ça, ça
existe. Les régies de l'énergie,
ça donne des emplois, ça donne vos vos
vos besoins essentiels et ça donne de la
cohésion sociale et ça vous donne aussi
votre retour sur investissement quand
même. Donc de ça. Ensuite, les
investissements. On doit absolument
provoquer, nous les acteurs de
l'économie régénérative
un mouvement qui permette de nous
déclarer, de dire qu'on existe, de dire
notre performance pour attirer les
investissements industriels, financiers
et des pouvoirs publics.
Autre questionnet. La dictature des
sages de Platon reste-t-elle une utopie
?
La dictature des sages de Plateau, c'est
quoi ça ? Je pas compris. On
pos la question.
Autre question.
Ah, c'est les gens comme là comme moi là
sur le fauteuil.
Je ne sais pas.
Ah bon ? Alors, il se trouve que dans la
transition, la plupart des théoriciens,
des intellectuels, de ceux qui écrivent
des bouquins sont aussi des
entrepreneurs parce qu'on doit en vivre.
Donc, on n'est pas tellement des sages
de plateau pour le coup.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la guerre
des graines des associations comme
Cocopellie,
Cocopellie
qui cherchent à sauvegarder le vivant ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de du fait que
des industriels
breuvettent le vivant
et la France est la meilleure he
là-dessus ?
Je vous laisse terminer.
La guerre des graines super documentaire
de Stenka qui est et Clément Montfort
dispose sur internet.
Alors je l'ai pas vu mais c'est un des
secteurs que j'avais que j'avais com
enfin quand j'étais dans chez les
agriculteurs biologiques. Ouai j'étais
dans je m'étais occupé justement des
semences.
C'est essentiel. Alors, il faut savoir
que en effet la France est un des pays
les plus stricts sur la réglementation
des semences.
On a donc et quand on empêche les
agriculteurs de de d'utiliser des
semences anciennes, euh comment on fait
? C'est ça qui est assez fou. On on on
coupe toute la filière en fait. C'est
complètement dingue. On on interdit à
celui qui qui
cultive la graine, enfin qui pardon qui
produit la graine parce qu'il faut bien
les produire les semences de les
cultiver et ou et et celui qui les
cultive de les ventre. D'accord ? C'est
ça le le socle en fait du problème des
semences en France. Et euh et alors ceci
dit, ça a bougé récemment. Ça a bougé
récemment et j'ai pas été regardé dans
le détail, mais le socle du problème, il
était là. Et euh et en fait, pourquoi c
c'est c'est
insupportable ? Parce que c'est notre
autonomie. C'est notre dernière
autonomie et parce que aussi c'est quand
même à la fois un patrimoine du vivant,
donc pas d'une compagnie et un
patrimoine d'une sélection qui s'est
faite par l'humanité depuis 8000 ans.
Je On va prendre d'autres trois petites
questions. Est-ce que vous avez un sujet
que vous voulez aborder avec nous ?
Euh la je pense que le enfin je sais pas
le je crois que la le
web et la data.
Ouais voilà le web et la data pour moi
c'est très important ça.
Allez-y. Est-ce que le web ça pollue ?
Est-ce que la data ça pollue ? Alors,
est-ce que
moi alors je pourrais pas vous faire la
démonstration là parce que c'est une
démonstration qui fait 30 pages quand
même. Mais mais en effet
faudrait il faut moi je rêverais d'une
sorte de acaton où on fasse on on
applique la la théorie de l'économie
symbiotique au web. Enfin, j'en ai fait,
je vous dis, elle est présente dans le
bouquin et que avec les données et les
mathé maticiens pour faire les les
équations à partir de la théorie et je
pense que on peut en effet avoir un
internet, des ordinateurs pour toute
l'humanité
de façon durable, c'est-à-dire en allant
vers le zéro extraction. Oui, parce
qu'il y a un tel gâi. Non, mais si c'est
c'est possible, c'est économiquement,
physiquement possible et cetera parce
que aujourd'hui, on est sur un gâchier
énorme. Donc voilà, donc c'est énorme
hein ce que je viens de dire. Personne
ne peut être d'accord avec moi et
cetera. J'ai fait une démonstration dans
le bouquin et j'aimerais vraiment faire
un gâon là-dessus. Si quelqu'un a envie
de l'organiser, je suis mais ultra
partante sur la démocratie du web. Il
faut absolument qu'on on ne peut pas en
fait aller contre un réseau quand ils
sont installés. Donc on les géant du web
aujourd'hui nous on est pied point lié.
On est tous sur Facebook. Bon, on prend
d'autres moteurs de recherche que
Google, mais bon, quand même, on est
tous sur ces ces truc là parce que en
fait l'intérêt d'être dans un réseau,
c'est de rencontrer du monde. Donc, à
partir du moment où un réseau a agrégé
assez de monde, il devient
indétronnable. Il devient indétronnable.
Donc, il faut attendre une nouvelle
vague du web. Et la nouvelle vague du
web qui peut arriver, c'est les
plateformes locales.
Et si elles sont en open source, en
gouvernance partagée notamment sur les
datas, et bien là on a les moyens de
faire à partir du local et à partir de
d'investissement public au départ, mais
qui qui de de de proposer des
plateformes qui soient qui vous
permettent votre e-commerce, votre votre
covoiturage, votre information sur votre
vos associations, sur les décisions
municipales, politiques et cetera. Et en
plus, si c'est en open source, ça permet
d'être sur votre monnaie complémentaire.
On a déjà des plateformes en open source
pour faire des monnaie complémentaires.
C'est les anglais là qui l'ont fait. On
de de reprendre à un endroit. La ville A
développe un truc, la ville B reprend ça
mais développe un autre module que la
ville A va reprendre et ainsi de suite,
ainsi de suite. Et donc on a vraiment la
possibilité de mutualiser les
investissements et au fur et à mesure de
faire un réseau mondial.
Alors, je vais poser une question d'un
sceptique qui datait de 20h33.
Pensez-vous vraiment que des
incantations peuvent changer les choses
?
Non,
il faut passer à l'action.
Oui.
À l'action ferme, dure.
Oui. À Ah ! Ah ! Ça dépend ce que vous
appelez l'action. Moi, pour moi,
l'action c'est entreprendre. Pour moi,
l'action c'est c'est
mais mettre ça dans le réel quoi. Faire
les entreprises, faire les structures
juridiques, produire et faire circuler
l'argent qu'on investit et l'argent
qu'on gagne comme ça. C'est ça le vrai
réel. C'est ça le vrai réel.
Croissance ou décroissance ?
Alors, c'est une économie de croissance.
H c'est une économie de croissance. Mais
la croissance n'est pas son but. C'est
une conséquence en fait. C'est-à-dire
que vous n'avez pas de croissance si
vous vous n'avez pas constitué cet
écosystème social et économique.
Donc voilà, c'est mais mais si
c'est son point faible.
Non ben non, le vivant croit.
Il y a des crois quand il y en a trop.
Mais le vivant, le vivant c'était une
planète nue la Terre il y a 3,5
milliards d'années,
c'était une planète nue. On n' jamais eu
même maintenant autant de diversité
biologique, autant de biomasse sur la
planète.
C'est quoi vos sources ?
Bah c'est euh c'est n'importe quel
n'importe quel cours d'écologie,
biologie, on vous le dira.
Et euh et euh et on a quand on a eu des
ruptures en fait comme la canobactérie,
comme la mitochondrie qui ont amené des
ruptures de du type la photosynthèse, la
respiration, des ruptures énergétiques
en réalité qui ont favorisé une une
efficience de l'énergie, une
productivité, elles sont devenues plus
denses, plus industrieuses.
Et bien, on a eu un un déploiement du
vivant énorme. et un déploiement du
vivant dans ses formes, dans ses
couleurs, dans ses mouvements, dans ses
dans dans ces ces ces enf vous avez des
trucs de dingue dans le vivant et et
donc non, c'est pas la croissance, c'est
pas le problème, c'est le contenu de la
croissance. Il se trouve que le vivre en
croit avec des externalités positives,
c'est-à-dire qu'il va vous amener en
même temps le il va en même temps épurer
l'eau, en même temps amener la
nourriture, en même temps apporter de
l'ombrage à lui et cetera. Voilà. et il
y a un équilibre qui se forme. Même même
les grands prédateurs en fait
rééquilibrent les les écosystèmes. Donc
voilà. Donc on a on a ça. Non, la
croissance c'est pas le problème. Le
problème c'est l'extraction. Le problème
c'est l'extraction.
Et en fait je sais que il faut faudrait
du temps en fait mais il faut lire le
livre. Mais en effet le la ces modèles
de de ces modèles de réassemblage et
cetera au niveau local. C'est des
échanges économiques mais qui sont sur
la réutilisation et pas sur
l'extraction. Notre croissance
aujourd'hui se fait sur l'extraction.
Une question qui n'a rien à voir. Les
chasseurs, c'est des amis ou c'est des
ennemis ?
Ah ben enfin, ça dépend des équilibres
mais en tout cas il est clair que
aujourd'hui c'est des c'est carrément
des ennemis dans l'état dans laquelle
est la biodiversité.
C'est carrément des ennemis. Après,
peut-être que sur certaines espèces qui
ont été introduites, qui deviennent
invasives et cetera là, OK, mais en ce
moment, mais non. Non, quoi.
Il va où le cartouche de le plomb des
cartouches ?
En plus, en plus en plus,
il y a combien de tonnes il y a combien
de tonnes de plombers ? Monstrueux.
C'est monstrueux.
Euh, pourquoi pense-t-elle que le
nucléaire est dangereux ?
Parce qu'il est mutagène. Parce que
lorsque il explose, il vous iradit toute
une population. Il immobilise des terres
et souvent des terres fertiles puisque
c'est c'est dans des zones quand même
assez peuplé. Vous regardez hein le
risque nucléaire en France, on est à peu
près tous concernés.
Croyez-vous qu'on a encore le temps
entre parenthèses effondrement ?
Je ne sais pas. C'est bien pour ça qu'il
faut agir si on savait.
Alors question de Abalou. Le problème
n'est-il pas démographique pour
l'interrogration ? Si on était 1 million
sur cette terre, le problème ne
serait-il pas résolu ? dans on a on a
discuté de ça avant et puis euh
il a dû prendre le direct en en cours.
On arrive à la fin de notre de notre
interview. Est-ce que vous avez des
livres à nous conseiller ? Trois. Alors
je le choc amoureux de Francesco
Alberoni, je pense que ça c'est vraiment
essentiel à tous ceux qui qui souhaitent
que ça change. Euh
là, j'ai découvert Pens la terreur qui
en fait une synthèse de nos rapports
vivants en fait entre les différentes
courants philosophiques, des grandes
civilisations en fait philosophiques,
mythologiques, spirituel et cetera et
que je trouve vraiment prodigieux. Ça
répondrait à votre question sur les
indigènes d'ailleurs, je pense. Euh donc
les pensées la terre, j'ai trouvé
vraiment un boutin bouquin de synthèse
merveilleux.
Et puis euh et puis parce que je crois
qu'il faut vraiment faire monter la
pensée écoéministe en France, ce qui a
été un vrai tabou.
C'est quoi une pensée écoéministe ?
C'est je suis tombée dans le tabou moi
alors qu'en fait je me rends compte que
je suis écoéministe depuis toujours.
L'écoféminisme c'est reconnaître c'est
un mouvement américain qui pense
l'effondrement qui né dans les années 70
et féminin et qui qui en fait dit que
les causes de la domination de la terre
et donc de la crise écologique sont les
mêmes causes que la domination des
femmes et de toutes les populations
dominées dans le monde. Ça fait beaucoup
en fait et et
qui qui est vraiment fabuleux. C'est
c'est le c'est le mouvement de pensée
qui réforme le plus et sur le fond et
sur la forme en fait. La pensée la
pensée occidentale, c'est un des plus
riches. Et donc je je le troisème ce
serait révé obscur
de Star qui est très dérangeant
et qui est très interpellant. C'est
magie femme et politique.
Il y a encore une question d'ailleurs.
Total qui se rapproche des grandes
écoles à sa clé, on en pense quoi ? On
fait quoi ?
J'ai pas bien compris. Pardon.
Total le l'entreprise Totale qui se qui
se rapproche des grandes écoles à sa
clé.
On en pense quoi ? On fait quoi ? Mais
je pense que de devant des entreprises
comme ça, il faut vraiment pas euh le
problème le problème de Total par
rapport à Total, c'est qu'on continue
d'utiliser du pétrole.
Donc voilà, donc
c'est un peu nécessaire quand même.
Carburant, bah c'est ça. Donc c'est
facile de de de
enfin voilà de toujours dire total mais
voilà tant que on a une économie qui est
tributaire du pétrole et qu'on n pas
entrepris comme je vous disais produits
et cetera autrement massivement mais ça
peut se faire localement, ça peut partir
du local,
et bien on aura toujours le problème
total. Le problème total quand même
aujourd'hui, c'est quand même un peu les
positions de Pouyané. Voilà qui sont
quand même
Oui. Patrick Pouyané qui sont pas
vraiment là
on a besoin de d'une d'une vraie pensée
d'industrie pétrolière.
Aujourd'hui l'industrie pétrolière on
peut pas faire son
même si on voudrait. Et moi ma la
théorie de l'économie symbiotique, elle
vraiment les énergies fossiles
d'ailleurs elles ne sont Ouais. Non, on
ça enfin voilà ça disparaît d'ailleurs
les énergies fossiles. C'est vrai que ça
disparaît mais euh c'est dans une
économie symbique parfaite. Mais
entre-temps, de toute façon, on a besoin
du pétrole. Donc, on a besoin de ces
acteurs-là et on a besoin de de les
mettre face à leur responsabilité
sociale et et et à la capacité
d'investissement qu'ils ont, à la
capacité d'organisation aussi qu'ils ont
parce que ces grandes entreprises ont
une grande capacité d'organisation
et et de de de
voilà de les mettre devant leur
responsabilité et de faire pourquoi pas
enfin je veux dire, ils sont tous
embêtés là avec leur raffinerie, leur
station essence et cetera Euh ils ont
des des une vraie qui ferme donc il ils
sont obligés de redistribuer enfin ils
sont obligés de s'occuper du territoire
contractuellement. Ben profitons de ça.
Profitons de ça pour voir comment on
réhabilite ces friches et de façon de
façon écologique, sociale et et
économique des nouveaux investissements.
Je peux prolonger un peu l'interview en
même temps ? On
on on s'est toujours sorti on s'est
toujours sorti d'un choc économique,
d'une récession par une surconsommation
énergétique.
Comment vous pensez qu'on va sortir du
choc économique qu'on est en train de se
prendre ? Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
va appliquer un peu de vos idées avec
des idées un peu plus
écologiques ?
Alors, je vais vous répondre déjà au
grandire le monde d'avant mais en pire.
Alors, on on vit un truc inédit pour
l'humanité, hein. On vit une crise
écologique. La dernière, c'était il y a
64 millions d'années. Nous, on en a au
maximum 6. Donc, on l'a jamais connu,
hein. Donc, remettons le temps qu'on
vit. On n' jamais connu ce temps-là.
Donc, le choc du vivant, les chocs qu'a
connu le vivant. Justement, c'est très
c'est très intéressant parce que quand
je vous parlais de la de la cano de la
canobactérie, de la mitochondrie tout à
l'heure, ils ont fait partie des
méthodes de résilience par rapport à des
chocs du vivant.
Et euh la cannobactérie par exemple
avant de produire l'oxygène qui qui a
qui a qui a fait l'explosion de vie sur
terre,
elle a elle a elle a produit une
extinction massive parce que c'était un
déchet
et personne savait utiliser l'oxygène
quoi. Donc et même pas elle d'ailleurs.
Donc c'était une catastrophe écologique.
Et finalement
elle
voilà la et pourtant elle est à
l'origine de la photosynthèse. Elle est
à l'origine de la photosynthèse. C'est
ce qu'il a sauvé, c'est la mitochondrie.
La mitochondrie qui installe une
symbiose parce que elle elle permet
d'utiliser l'oxygène qu'elle amène dans
la réaction chimique et de sortir le CO2
que l'huile végétal absorbe. Et là
deuxième boom énergétique. Deuxième boom
énergétique sur l'efficience en fait. Et
donc et deuxième boom de croissance.
Donc ça c'est quand même intéressant
vous voyez. C'est-à-dire que c'est elle
a pas utilisé plus d'énergie, mais elle
a utilisé d'autres modes et qui ont qui
ont permis de résoudre la crise. Alors
sur la crise économique actuelle et bien
euh
je c'est difficile, on peut pas on peut
rien prévoir en fait et on peut rien
prévoir. Ce que je crois c'est que ça
dépendra énormément notamment des
réactions de la population, de la
solidarité qui va y avoir localement et
cetera et de du de la fabrique de sens.
Je vous coupe
parce que attendez parce que si on est
dans des mécanismes de peur, on va
tomber dans des dans des dans des
gouvernements qui seront pas du tout
écologique populiste et pas écologique.
Je me permets de rebondir avec une
question d'internet de Pap Diouf.
Comment moi jeune de 19 ans, je peux
aider à ce renversement ?
Ah ben alors déjà franchement ouf.
Heureusement que les jeunes sont là
quoi. Heureusement qu'ils font la grève
du lycée en disant à quoi ça sert que
que j'étudie des choses qui alors que
vous me foutez en l'air mon avenir.
Franchement,
c'est légitime
mais totalement. Puis alors c'est une de
celles qui qui vulgarise le mieux les
discours scientifiques. Faut le savoir
quand même. Faut arrêter de dire que
franchement moi je suis épatée de son
niveau en en quelques phrases.
C'est l'ancienne prof qui parle.
Ouais. Ouais.
Et puis l'ancienne vulgarisatrice de
parce que quand j'écrivais home, j'avais
pas le droit à une erreur en fait. Sinon
tout le film donc j'allais voir tous les
scientifiques.
Euh donc non mais déjà ça c'est
extrêmement important dire sa colère.
Beaucoup d'étudiants viennent me voir
mais et pour organiser par exemple il y
avait il y a eu des étudiants qui ont
organisé la le cours enfin l'université
qu'on veut au 21e siècle. Il faut voir
ce qu'ils vivent. Ils sont ils sont
toute la journée donc c'est ces études
c'est pas drôle enfin c'est pas drôle en
train de en train de d'apprendre des
choses dont ils sont convaincus qu'ils
ne leur serviront pas que c'est dépassé
et ils doivent avoir leur diplôme. On a
une génération qui est c'est terrible ce
qu'elle vit. C'est terrible. Moi, je
trouve que ce qu'elle vit est terrible à
tous les niveaux. Au niveau de l'avenir,
au niveau du quotidien, au niveau C'est
terrible. Donc il faut continuer et euh
et euh et euh et en effet, il y a plein
de choses à faire. Enfin, il y a je
pense à une stagiaire que j'avais eu qui
faisait des disques soupes par exemple
et euh qui euh elle avait fait par
exemple la disco soupe de des premiers
sans barbares
et euh et du coup ça avait énormément
popularisé le disque soupe et puis et
elle avait mis tout l'immeuble au
compost. Enfin, truc de dingue quoi.
C'est-à-dire qu' elle partait du compost
et puis euh et puis ça ça ça passait
dans tout le tout le bureau et puis bon,
il se trouve que c'était aussi ce
mouvement là. Mais du coup en fait ça a
fait une discussion soup puis du coup ça
ça comme c'est un mouvement quand même
assez influent. Ça a popularisé la
discos soupe. C'est voilà.
La disco soupe. C'est
Ah oui, pardon. La discos soup c'est
c'est un truc assez génial. C'est c'est
un mode d'emploi fait par une par une
nana d'ailleurs, je crois au départ qui
dit ralbol des invendus alimentaire et
donc et de du gaspillage alimentaire et
qui propose une méthode qui dit "Bon, on
va chercher les invendus alimentaires
dans les supermarchés, dans les marchés
et cetera. Voilà comment vous procédez
et cetera parce qu'ils vont vous dire ça
machin habituel. vous les euh on les
utilise pour une soirée où on cuisine
avec en musique en donc l'idée de de
d'être ensemble pour cuisiner et que ce
soit la fête, donc c'est pas du tout
l'écologie du sacrifice et euh et en
même temps on met des panneaux sur pour
sensibiliser tous les participants de
cet événement
euh bah en grand problème et puis aux
invendus alimentaires.
C'est pas une question. C'est bien de
parler des étudiants mais des jeunes qui
ont commencé à travailler de peu 19 24
ans. On peut faire quoi ?
Il faut savoir quand même que c'est le
monde enfin je les
on est en pleine mutation économique, on
est en pleine mutation sociale. Donc
c'est très
faut retourner à des métiers qui
traitent la terre. Il faut retourner
l'élevage correct. Il faut remonter les
centres équestes.
C'est là c'est là où j'adore
l'expérience par exemple des mureaux qui
disaient enfin qui dit territoire zéro
chômeur. Enfin pour ceux qui qui
connaissent qui sont pas dans la région
parisienne, les muraux c'est un c'est un
c'est au bord de la scène hein. C'est
c'est quand même un endroit chouette
et et c'est un ghetto et et c'est un des
endroits où il faut surtout pas habiter
en Île-de-France et qui ont déclaré où
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de pauvreté,
beaucoup de discrimination et où ils ont
déclaré territoire zéro. Ils ont fait un
un pôle de un PT, ce qu'on appelle un
PCTE, un pôle de coopération, pôle
territorial de coopération et d'emploi
et et
objectif zéro chômeur, le ville
touristique à l'horizon je sais plus
combien et et c'est en train de se
faire. Le local par exemple, comment
elle s'appelle ? Coline Ser, on a fait
un film d'ailleurs. Il son un village de
2000 habitants. Il a créé plus 100
emplois avec des politiques comme on
vient de dire. Voilà les partout où on a
fait des coopératives énergétiques
citoyennes, partout où on a fait de la
régie municipale alimentaire, on a créé
des emplois
et ce ne sont que quelques exemples.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Continuez.
Continuez. On a besoin de vous.
On a je crois vraiment dans ma
génération, on a été quelques-uns mais
la génération enfin mais on n'est pas
une génération qui a agi voyez et et
même ceux qui ont agi n'ont pas eu la
génération avant qui avait les manettes
pour pouvoir le le pour pour pour les
écouter pour écouter les jeunes
générations. Les générations qui avaient
les manettes ne les ont pas écouté. Là,
je leur dis, il faut absolument que la
génération de vos parents vous écoute
parce que c'est elle qui a le pouvoir
aujourd'hui. Le les pouvoirs dans les
conseils d'administration, les pouvoirs
d'achat, les pouvoirs de décision, on a
tous notre pouvoir de décision, les
pouvoirs dans son propre quartier de
faire des choses et cetera. Donc
continuez, il faut que la génération,
notre génération à nous euh de les
parents de cette génération-là, elle
elle l'embrayille, elle les suivent.
Vous savez ce que je crois même
aujourd'hui ? Je me demande à quel point
on ne devrait pas faire un droit de vote
proportionnel au temps qui reste à vivre
sur la terre. C'est-à-dire que les
jeunes vont se taper tout l'avenir qui
est terrible
et ils sont, je trouve beaucoup plus
légitime
à voter, à décider que la d'ailleurs la
majorité des votants aujourd'hui parce
que il y a toute une un poids qui ne
vote pas, qui a plus de 56 ans je crois.
Malheureusement, c'est comme ça. C'est
c'est peut-être une question de
temporalité, hein, et d'époque. Mais
aujourd'hui, mon Dieu, c'est les plus
informé.
Ils savent entreprendre d'une façon de
folie. Ils ont le nouveau mindset
et c'est eux qui vont gérer la
catastrophe.
Isabelle de la noix, merci.
Je vous en prie, c'est moi. Merci.
[Musique]